so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
yo yo what is going on realm i see y'all
in there general mac yo salute i see the
video what's going on oh my god what's
going on let's give me that net what's
up
hustle and motivate let me know how i'm
sounding out here how the levels is
doing
talk to me right quick you know i'm
saying game plan oh sit low two dollar
super chat iop in the daytona 500
best sunday ever okay you going around
the laps i see you gaming fire what's
going on
what's going on yo pragmatic eagle what
up we got the legendary aerial knight
already here
oh my man black conflict x is in here
you know how i get when i see that name
salute hollywood rules what's going on
i'm sounding good i'm sounding good
bob let's get our aerial nitrous just do
a mic check right quick it's right quick
what i would say is what i mean i'll
tell you to do it like one more
adjustment with the attic you still
there you talk to the people
no doubt no doubt one more time one more
time
hello there you go there you go all
right cool thank you sir hustler
motivate yeah we're gonna get everybody
in the run scrub nervous what's up the
dusty one what up fatigue what's going
on yeah my man king coming up soon oh
wow who's this ko3 black truth ten
dollar super chat get hard geek as a
guest asap i didn't know how geek does
uh podcast that's what's up okay asante
what's going on
lydian master what's going on talk to me
big show today i'll be always on sunday
you already know so look we're going to
mute we're going to get king of here
because he's going about to hit us with
that content strike with the music
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical
[Music]
welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack do all
that good stuff that we need to do and
um you know we're about to get started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh i guess i'm here to
keep you entertained until the time to
get this show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the snapple and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people on aim
[Music]
for them to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you're just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals follow on twitter but
i'm anti-social love my city but i'm
still by coastal
[Music]
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell the uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and had this be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
check
[Music]
your dog thing very loyal but i ain't
gonna hold you i ain't here to boy you
ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed for
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that
again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable i
kill a beating they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal but they'd be like why use a
video game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable and
they say i'm better than money because
you can bank on me being accountable i
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that
again you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tiller uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak uh i
guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's who
let's do it
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's the avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though i know it's
my destiny word to carnita who cares if
you fly if you steal a mosquito you
swear you ain't something but really be
stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday and suitable
cause you can listen to this in your
cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
i see levels so i'm hoping the audio is
fine
welcome to the iron laws podcast llc and
also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 245. it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's date i'm extremely
excited about our returning guest and
we've got the update to ariel knights
never yield horizon forbidden west
impressions ea and miss battlefield's
failed expectations and a rumored street
fighter 6 to discuss so we gonna get
right into it
i want to introduce a lord whose
creation of a stylish narrative runner
with anime sensibilities and the most
absolute banging beats has recently
breathed life back into the video game
culture
introducing the independent game
developer and creator of the aerial
knight never yield franchise
ilp's future class in game dev
creator of our favorite anime axel foley
who inspires us all to never yield to
obstacles put in our path
live from motor city detroit
and making his successful return into
the realm of the lords
my man lord ariel knight a.k.a neil
jones how we doing sir
yo hey what's up
yo
what's going down what's going on
brother how you fed that lot going on in
your world what's been going on how you
feeling control so man
besides aerial night now all stuff we'll
get into what have you been playing sir
oh i've been playing a lot and trying to
catch up uh
you know making game take all you know
pretty much take all the time so i've
been playing a lot of indie games i've
been playing
uh just like a lot of shorter games yeah
um a lot of stuff that i missed out on
with you know playstation plus and games
gold and all that stuff um but like
right this second um
i played that roller coaster
and i uh started like two days ago uh
lost judgment oh okay you don't judge me
yeah they saying just turn they saying
you're a little low again just turn up a
little bit if you can on your own
yeah yeah they want they want to hit it
when they hear you man
i see you so that's been as far as that
as far as any other little games got a
chance stuck in or just been it's busy
that you can only probably get those in
right now
yeah just a bunch of indie games you
know
too many in the name but you know
whatever any game you didn't saw uh
that's the pretty much the one i've been
trying to play
no doubt you already know and we're
supposed to have the four horsemen of
gaming but one of them we don't know
where he is about the game he should be
he should be joining in progress so
don't worry somebody say yo did jack put
king on the bench after last week died
which i did with him was fine i saw that
titanic meme y'all have been saw put
them in
that was wow i got it
king
king's in the bottom of the ocean that's
right yeah yeah they were playing the
violins they did the titanics and it was
perfect timing how they did it yo y'all
was fine yeah i cut that up real quick
yeah that was really quick you guys are
special yeah yeah they they was on it
with that one but anyway i got my
co-host my brother from another mother
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
my man lord addict of the attic show how
we doing sir
doing pretty good man i've been playing
destiny all
week trying to catch up
and you know i could safely i feel
comfortable you know i got maybe one or
two more things i got to do before i
feel
uh that i need before i go into this
expansion but i'm hyped man i'm hyped
for this witch queen i need this i need
this in my life
uh unfortunately between me and which
queen is the dentist appointment so
that's that's horrible but you know
after that we good we good man
except for that tuesday launch that i
probably have to wait three hours before
i could actually get on destiny but yeah
besides that we we good man and that
plus i watched uh i watched on charter
the charges that was a pretty good movie
early early uh you know impressions
um
if you really enjoy
the the games i can understand why you
would feel away about this
but
it's like it's like i said yesterday to
when i was talking to kog like if i
wanted to watch
the story of uncharted four one two and
three
i would go play uncharted four one two
or three
i don't need the exact same story
because then i feel like what's the
point of going or watching it if you
know the beginning middle and end so i i
felt like as its own standalone it's
it's good but i understand you know they
they did mess up certain things and they
use certain material from the games
which you've seen in the trailers but
it's just like they did that because it
was fan selective that's they wanted to
do that for you guys not for you to
complain on on twitter
no doubt
and of course we have almost technical
gaming lord the solo gamer list for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus
the lord of clarity and lord patron of
the iron bake my man lord sovereign how
we doing sir i'm in the bushes
why are you in the bushes though what's
going on my eyes hurt i need the shame i
need to sleep all right i need
everything so you know
i'm good i'm good
you expect it yeah man everybody's not
feeling well yeah man no not but i'm
actually i've been fine but just this
you know a little while ago i was like
oh my god why are my eyes on fire what
did i do yeah you gotta probably wrestle
man you know what it is i'm hurt yeah it
is it is it is rest so
but yeah i i played about i would say
seven to eight hours of uncharted i mean
excuse me of of uh horizon forbidden
west so we'll talk about that in a
little bit um
a lot of you saw me document the horrors
that were the uh the mlb the show 22
tech tests
on the nintendo switch i saw the frames
bruh i saw the face bruh did you partake
i i i did that for takes oh brother good
good i saw enough i thought i'm gonna
wait for them to work out the cakes i
don't know what it what's the the the
golf obviously look how they massacred
my boy like look at him
yeah you know again i i did see some
improvement during the course of the
tech test first so maybe they're
tweaking stuff and
i just if it's a solid 30 by the time it
comes out
i'll still consider it but at this at
this point if this is the product that
we're getting in a you know whatever a
month and change two months
nah
beyond that i've been uh again uh
pecking away at uh sifu thing about sifu
is if you don't stay consistent and play
during the week which i can't
you gotta like you gotta just remember
your skills when you come back yeah
get thrashed so um yeah i'm still in
that third stage but still having fun
with cfo i think it's a fantastic game
um and then i had my nephew uh overnight
last night and
remember snipperclips yes the um that
was a launch game yeah
yes i bought it at launch not realizing
i really needed someone to play with and
they said i never got around to playing
it so it's been sitting there i'm like
oh let's play this right so he's nine
finally so he could follow instructions
and stuff so we were having a good time
for a while but then he has like adds so
he like after like 10 minutes all he was
doing was cutting me up and not wanting
to to do the objectives
but the game is fun man i love it that
game is really fun really really fun you
got to do the shape so you got to work
together and form yourself
yeah it's really fun mm-hmm so it might
take me two years to finish it with him
but you would go for that they got the
four-player mode too yes they do yes
they do that's crazy so that's it that's
pretty much it no doubt and of course we
usually have
uh the combat talk king the prophet of
xbox but um sadly lord king has called
out today he's not feeling well he's
really not feeling well because oh
really yeah yeah he's not feeling well
we will definitely rough it's like no no
i know the man got to rest some time too
he's not we told him to shut it down so
he's not doing good but okay still got
the gaming ninja himself the shinobi
lord king a lot of lord king
look
i know i'm speaking for on his behalf
spreading the reality of the realm of
the iop not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear yo shout
out to my man maddie plays latest
defining dude breaking down that
platinum game situation also um yo the
right yeah they be clowning maddie
they're trying to come for the fashion
they're trying to come for as fast as
that was absolutely hilarious check him
out he's doing his thing and then of
course we got the um the patreon and we
have the game of thrones edition kind of
like uh the white walkers who's next on
the on the out front as far as
competition for xbox that most people
are not probably taken seriously so
check that out you know the amazons the
the googles the you know what i'm saying
all that stuff so check that out and
then last word with ibottus and thai guy
travis we had the legendary four out
plays yo check that out we get the witch
queen hype going you know what i'm
saying talking about the gambit changes
and all that and um of course the uh you
want to check that out that is up on iop
the last words playlist but um for me
personally it's been destiny i'm just
like attic i'm getting in my bag i've
been getting all my exotics everything i
need all my god roll legendary so
whatever bungee wouldn't do with the
sandbox i'm ready i'm trying to get raid
ready and the grind is going to be so
question yeah when y'all jump into this
yeah
because my impression is when you guys
get a big expansion like a lot of stuff
kind of gets overwritten right when it
starts and you they're going to have
their own weapons and stuff like that so
is all this stuff you're getting going
to matter yes though
but caveat what they're doing is they're
introducing crafting
and crafting is cool but then a lot of
these crafted weapons are going to be
able to have extra traits that based on
the activities that you play and stuff
like that that will give them bonuses
that will make them
eventually superior than your current
stuff once you craft out and do you know
how destiny do it's sunsetting without
sunsetting okay right right so crafting
when you say crafting cause the last
time i played destiny it was that you
could feed you could feed lesser guns
into better guns yes to improve those
guns right yeah is that still a thing
and yeah that that that's just infusion
the fusion has to get your light level
up but what what
that will always be a mainstay but
crafting is like going to a specific
thing you get a crafted weapon and then
basically they want you almost d1 style
but not as grindy where they want you to
use the weapon and get kills and
specific activity to unlock perks and
then you can kind of get customized into
your kind of format the perks or roles
that you like based on what you receive
so there's a little bit of rng with the
crafting but it is really cool so that
obviously seafood been trying to rock
that and um demio man damion was talking
with neil earlier and you know we had
attic going last night shout out to jan
said shout out to petey he streamed it
you know what i'm saying shout out to
pity last now though tv we're just
rocking out and we got to like the
second level we're getting handled in
the first time like when you got new
people that's demio that don't know what
they doing
first level is kind of the cake where
you just kind of get used to stuff and
the second level was to turn up the
first level like we was getting handled
dude i was like oh man this is this is
looking spooky and then addict's head
sick went out and then we're just like
we're calling the night after the first
level of the dungeon but that was that
salute she looked everybody though it's
bad before warning you that i'm gonna
get cursed out this weekend yeah we're
gonna have to run two teams we usually
run in like the the double team
situation so because so many people want
to play you're going to fall but check
that out and we got uh some stuff
special how about coming up with deal
demio on iop so check that out so i'm
gonna get the super chat before we get
into this yeah yeah let's get this let's
go
all right so we got sith lord with the
two dollars we chat iop and the daytona
500 best sunday ever daytona 5. wow i
haven't been watching daytona 500 in
years
uh ko3 black truth 10 super chat get
hargett as a guest asap argentino
and we have don otaku 5
played the switch sports beta and the
bowling battle royale was such a good
idea tennis and chambara were also fun
playing online no issues yeah that is
the beta i should have played thank you
sir
[Laughter]
there we have tazo ichi 10 super chat
realm unite please go to this week's
episode of defining duke get it to 1000
likes oh and share so that lord cog and
mr maddie have to try a peanut butter
and onion sandwich hashtag
you need to stop first of all you're
listening to the show which is good but
i don't like that situation
but here's the thing i blame jazz he
started this whole onion sandwich
british culture at the bar thing and
then they like yeah then people like yo
that that's lit we know about that and
i'm like fam who raised you like who's
eating onion sandwiches i see i'm not
going out of my way to do it like for me
like let's say i have like a steak
sandwich with like caramelized onions on
it whatever and then some of the onions
fall off or whatever i finish off the
steak and i still have bread like on the
caramelized onions on that toasted bread
that's that's the thing i'm not going to
go out of my way to make that bro but if
the situation arises organically like
for sure i'm gonna do that but what's
getting me mad like you talking about it
in an accessory sense they're talking
about like that's the main course like
you go slap the onion on and be like
yeah this is how it's going down tonight
like who's talking to you after that
who's talking who is dealing with you in
your life that's after the sandwiches
and then they talking peanut butter they
wild and they wow but anyway
the peanut butter has to be they have to
be
jiving you no
apparently well i don't know about the
peanut butter part you're right i don't
know but apparently there's like combos
with this sandwich there's like this
it's a thing it's a thing apparently
shout out to european culture man yeah i
don't know who raised your saluta
[Laughter]
there we go butterball two dollar super
chat ordered the tcl tv that i will name
after king
i'm sure he appreciates that
tell us what you said nah fam you got to
do it cause you said yeah we just said
if we get a thousand likes on that joint
we we will eat uh
that's gonna be painful i don't know i
mean a regular onion sandwich okay but
even that wasn't nasty
we have drunken ninja member for 19
months
shout out to you sir good morning lord
this is the glorious sundays your boys
officially a series x owner no doubt
congrats sir well uh for the low thank
you gamestop let's get this work today
y'all no doubt thank gamestop coming
through
no doubt we have target cheney five
dollars for chat salute to the lords
hashtag playstations of monopoly
where spartacus hashtag remedy makes
crack games now oh wow
aztec horizon falls only at an 88 meta
hashtag ponyvision kills brainstorm ah
here we go here we go who all this hate
that's a lot of hate
a lot of hate for the course you forgot
right
so there's a new release come out for
something you know how this goes that
was a good i mean that was just
aggressive very aggressive very
aggressive very good
shout out to you so i haven't seen you
for a minute remember for 21 months
thank you shout out to the lords in chat
much respect for you guys keep up the
great work like and subscribe to the
great group bringing it each sunday
thank you sir
then we have flame remember for 17
months
dawn of the second day 48 hours remain
for which queen i blame halo have a good
show
everybody blames halo for their for
their either successes or failures i
guess
okay let me run back a little bit and we
have
necromancer zale member for four months
downlight 2 is fun playing cyberpunk
2077 with the new update and have eldon
ring and the witch queen pre-ordered so
much to do and no time to do it yeah for
sure
that is for sure now we have lord
metroid two dollars super chat king got
sick playing too much skyward swords
he retired
yeah get get your shots in get about get
them down yeah yeah here to defend
himself then we got clutch man five
dollar super chat
got my all natty white t my friend my
friend asked what does that mean i said
you gotta watch the show
it's like it's like a members-only
jacket like only you understand
few you know
there we go stitch 2000 which i i need
that link cog eating peanut butter and
onion oh jesus you're wild
all right we're caught up we're getting
all right we caught up we got a lot of
new people joining the realms hello big
man mo and all that also kids move the
best part was going when i see you snuck
through the back door you know what i'm
saying what's going on so how you doing
oh what up brother i'm good what's up uh
how you guys doing uh uh thanks to
addict for the i hope he hopefully gave
y'all a warning i ain't crashing all
right now you go you're familiar we
found out we already know the king is
down you know sometimes you gotta call
up the reinforcement sometimes exactly
yeah
i told cargo
how you been though just in general oh
yeah i've been i've i've been all right
um playing uh
horizon forbidden west a little bit of
uh dying um dying light too
and i'm probably i don't know i still
find halo pretty fun so i'm trying to
complete the battle pass there but i
don't know but keeping the light keeping
the light no doubt solution will solve
anything else we got to clean up before
yeah we got big mad mode remember for 20
months shout out to the lords of mr
knight no doubt thank you sir yo what's
good thanks
no doubt so you already know let's get
into this now we got to what the laws
have been playing we got to focus back
on lord ariel knight we already did his
video game system history and his
journey as a professor in 3d art way
back iop
181
so go catch that that's in the irp i'll
be exclusive interview section on the
playlist but uh enough all that you know
we're here for that main event and all
that goodness of what we hear so like
the great rick rule says hit the music
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
be back at it
[Music]
whoa my boy back my boy he's back
let's get it the aerial night
bars is back the flow is back it's good
to see you man so let's let's get into
it man you know got this new update you
know for the aerial nights never yield
so talk to the people what was your
mindset behind releasing the new update
the update
yeah man uh i was excited to get yelled
at um
i was reading people's feedback and
stuff like that you know uh kind of made
the game blind uh you know there's i
don't i don't have a studio a bunch of
testers or and whatnot so absolutely a
lot of this was like kind of just me
kind of just making stuff trying to
predict what people like just making the
game for me really so i took a lot of
feedback a lot of the comments and try
to make those adjustments and you know
add in what you know people kind of
asked for no doubt so taking the
feedback directly man that's so cool so
again we got the bonus levels
and a lot of people won't do that that's
the fact you know
it is one of those things where it's
like you realize that obviously some of
these people they they don't need to be
given criticism but there's a lot of
people that generally want a game to be
better and it's up to the developer to
take that as you know not an attack on
them or their game and attack to make
the game better and a lot of people
don't don't do that like that
respect
and a lot of people you know is charging
so let's get let's get let's be clear
like you know again free free update so
we we got leaderboards we got ui like we
so a lot of this again just for clarity
stuff that was kind of on the cutting
room floor and stuff that or just that
kind of looking at the streamers and
looking at the feedback and saying okay
you know what i could tighten this up
because you even added like more story
stuff like talk to me every night what's
going on here yeah the um the ending the
ending got rushed uh i know that i
i was doing it myself um i liked it uh
it was a little bit vague it was like
mysterious but people wasn't really
feeling it so uh brand new ending but uh
there was new bonus levels new music
endless mode leaderboards there's a
mobile version coming uh real soon uh
change the ui all together you know you
can you can see the no intro logo
new graphics updates you know i redid
the graphics for like three levels just
kind of redid it completely um like
story story tweaks you know you'll see a
bunch of new cutscenes
um i made adjustments to the levels you
know just kind of watching people play
it on twitch and whatnot i could see
where people got kind of got hung up on
like one or two obstacles so i kind of
just took those out and made adjustments
uh i fixed that that trophy that
everybody was saying yeah yeah yes it
was coming for you
hey hey it's a hard thing to fix people
don't understand
so so people don't understand the game
with the
is that as easy as people think
yeah man oh no no it's it's just a quick
it's just a button all he all he had to
do was let him switch i don't know what
was taking so long
just a button click man i could do it
where's the button i'll push it for you
like i don't get people
right the achievement hunters they came
from my neck real hard oh quick
two hours playing this game where's my
platinum
i feel that but yo look at that i'm
still
every single game release we've been
like trying to and i told you how i was
struggling for that last achievement
the last two achievements oh kid is
guilty
yeah i'm guilty like you know me but i
don't mind revisiting the game because
that you said you updated
uh
cut scenes
uh music the ending um and then you
fixed it so i i haven't i mean the game
is you know it's a it's not like you
know
like 20 hours
i told you this
when after you released the game after i
got through the game and i was trying to
get the rest of the achievements
when all fails i just went to my
favorite level with that had like the i
think it was level seven with that i
don't know the man
yeah the beat and everything i just
can't play that because it's just like
uh i like this level so i would play
that literally on repeat when i was like
i feel like playing aerial nights but
the thing is is that once you've done
everything well now i have a reason to
actually go and actually
finish it yeah but before all right once
you get the replays all right well i'm
gonna either do like uh
like uh a trouser or just replay my uh
favorite level now
the game was built so it was it was
fairly easy to get back into it and do
whatever you want like you could just go
back to any stage that we've done in the
past so it's just crazy they hear the
level of detail of what you've done
since listening to feedback and going
back and just going and going over and
beyond because some of this stuff people
like all right this patch is picked
sorry you're gonna get that but like you
literally went in and like oh okay uh
let me go re and install it and start
this game right now but um what i want
to point out too kid
is like
certain things is is one thing but like
aaron you went back and changed the
indie something that you
liked
people don't realize like to an artist
changing something for his fans that he
liked is a big thing like
yeah it's it's way better now you know
it's still
you know a little a little bit
mysterious you know um
you know it is what it is i was trying
to make more of a chill game something
you could just play and relax you know
stress you know it's uh somebody called
it a palette cleansing game so yeah
between your 200 hour games and i was
like hey that's perfect you know
especially with being on games of gold
um if you get it for free you kind of
just pick it up and you know you just
play it over uh you know uh sunday
afternoon oh yeah chill you ain't
playing it through the last day but
you're playing later on after sun
but that that's real talk though i mean
we'll get into the game's gold stuff um
a little later but i definitely want to
salute you again for going back in there
for me
playing yeah no doubt bro you know
playing it now
why i appreciate it is because you know
i never really play runners i'll be
honest with you and playing yours gave
me an appreciation of it and again it's
just like the in the foreground it
almost soft gave me
inside vibes because like there's parts
when you're going through the office and
you're seeing people like he's going
through stuff he's trying to get away
but it's like exactly yeah i ain't
babying stuff and i love stuff like i'm
gonna give it to you so a minute and
it's like the surveillance and all of
that you added for foliage the incline
decline stuff just sprint like little
nuances that i'm like yo i'm feeling it
you know the same kind of thing but okay
so he's about to jump in no no i just to
me the great thing about the game was
that
despite it being a runner and you you
you know the the premise of the game to
be to sort of get from point a to b you
know jump into obstacles whatever the
story being told
is unlike any other runner like it is a
real story and a narrative throughout
yes you know a lot of runners you play
them on your phone or whatever that's
not the conceit of that game this game
you took a genre where it's like you
said it can be very chill and tried to
add more and i think beyond that like
the the music the music
it makes it just as much of a rhythm
game yeah as a runner
and again when you look at other games
of this ilk
it's either you know something on your
phone or whatever designed to extract
money from you or whatever
this is not that like
to me
i don't think you got enough credit for
making this type of game in a way that
is it makes it feel
it makes it truly feel like a console
game right in a way that i don't know
that anybody ever really looked at a
runner like that like how do i make this
appeal
on a story level on a character level on
a style level and and the music oh my
god all the music is ridiculous the
music is a character and and i'll give
it of itself yeah because the thing
about it is let's be real and you can
probably attest to it too it's like
when we don't a lot of video games just
don't have
hip hop culture or just those be so when
you finally get again the protagonists
that kind of look like you you feel
connected to it already then you have
this beat and it's like when the beats
are knocking and you have the
sensibilities to you it'll make you
invest more you're like oh nah i gotta
that's the part with it you know what
i'm saying and then i like i want to
give you a credit you only did it a
couple times but i actually liked when
you attempted to do boss battles
in the game because now it's like okay
now we're going to switch to the
perspective the missiles are coming at
me i'm hopping i'm doing stuff like that
and it feels like elaine i was going to
ask you like i feel like you're kind of
creating a new sub-genre within the
genre which is a narrative runner like
you're trying to express and tell stuff
and you know what i'm saying like i'm
excited about i wanted to get your
thought process on that aspect with
those changes the boss battles the
narrative aspect and the music yeah man
y'all y'all hitting the nail on the head
so pretty much um
for me runners super boring you know
they've been done you know we go and
play it for like so long before you get
kind of tired of it
and that's kind of why i try to do that
so if you don't like runners if you hate
if you purely hate runners then you know
this ain't really for you this is more
for the people who ain't never played
runners before or just like kind of
always intimidated by them to just kind
of like you know bring them into that to
kind of give them that experience
because i don't want to make another
shooter i don't want to make you know
one of those like
pixar rpg things those are cool but
everybody makes those i feel like so i
kind of wanted to take a genre that
nobody was doing anything with and just
kind of bring it back do something
different with it put my own spin on it
and see how people like it and with the
boss battles
like i said um i was kind of doing this
blind i don't have a studio or anybody
to like kind of like test a bunch so um
i put a couple boss battles in there
just to see if people like them and if
people didn't like them then uh you know
uh then they didn't have to do them too
much but you know i now i know that
people like those kind of things so when
a white person comes and makes this game
they're going to be a bunch of warlock
battles in there
[Music]
listen boy addict we like balls but talk
to we love them both battles
you mute it at it you eat it you mute it
uh he's not beauty sorry about that oh
you're good you're all you're talking no
i'm saying we like them boss battles
though right
yeah i enjoy boss battles uh
[Music]
part like you know is your man austin a
back on
on on the lyrics is that him again it
was because
for the trailer um that that trailer
like
it was stuck in my head i wanted it real
specific i told him where to put that
gap like it was all planned out before
the update even came out um but you know
dan dan came back and did uh a mix for
the endless mode
austin came back and did the
did the trailer for me um and like what
people don't really kind of notice about
the game because they kind of like just
look at the surface level which is cool
i do the same thing but the ending of
the game those lyrics is literally what
the character's uh point of views are
the trailer that just came out literally
tells you the ending of the game in the
trailer in the challenge listen to it
yeah all right people listen to rap they
just kind of like listen to the beat
like all the lyrics everything that's in
the game matters like the people in the
background the where you're running
through like all that stuff um but you
could look at it really surface level
and just kind of play it that way too
and i think i think that's what's
important too like
you as a creator right you want you want
everybody to be able to experience kind
of and and get the stories that you want
to tell
out of it but at the same time the fact
that it can appeal to so many people on
those levels where like again my nephew
looks at it he's like oh this is cool
like i'm moving to it he doesn't care
what the lyrics take he just doesn't he
won't listen to it but again the
movement and and just the beat itself
brings him in so
i mean and that's a special thing as
well like
even if that isn't your intent the fact
that it can appeal to so many people on
it so many levels i think in the long
term it's gonna it's gonna make it that
much more appealing to that more that
many people it's the kids for real
though like
like yeah the really my my long term
the people playing it right now it's
like little kids they love this game um
and then when they come up playing it
they gonna play it again and say oh i
didn't notice that i didn't notice this
because you know it's really accessible
for them you don't have to memorize a
bunch of buttons yeah um it's like you
know it's cool so uh you know that's
that's kind of my long term it's like if
they if they're interested in it you
know when they come up they'll be like
hey i want to make a runner i want to
you know play this again or something
like that that's that's where the where
the hope is i showed it to my nephew and
he was like because he has on his tablet
he has temple run
and he has whatever that christmas
runner is the sand or something or
whatever
they're all
they're all temple run clones i showed
them your game he was like wow wait a
minute so you're going sideways mostly
you're not going towards the screen okay
that's cool
and it was just like and again he's not
you know he's he's
he's rhythm deficient that's it yo yo
that's me
what it is i love him
but he was just like
he was going when i was like yeah there
you go there you go
there you go
and no no micro transactions no
purchases you ain't got to worry about
none of that yup beat the level i saw
jackets unlocked i'm like okay i get my
actual foley on okay that's what i'm
talking
about could have easily went that route
with the cosmetics i respect that and
you added a lot of stuff to it and last
part of these before we move on um gotta
shout you out brad bro the vinyl you got
the vine you got it
you got the soundtrack
literally on wax
like talk to me about how that project
in like why was that important to you to
get the the soundtrack pressed up on
vinyl
i mean it just kind of happened really
like that that first first trailer came
out like a year and a half ago um people
hit me up they was like yo
let us do this for you and i was like
cool that was pretty much it wow so they
came to you
okay okay i will put that in the chat i
don't know if there's any available yet
chat but y'all got to go get that you
know what i'm saying the music box
it's the last run though so okay limited
edition if y'all want them
black screen records i see it right
there black screen records.com you go go
get that go get that you already know so
yeah we got that now the thing i got to
shout you out a lot of the chat is
already showing you out where i'm
extremely proud of you and it was a
surprise that
i saw watch them looking at the xbox
blog post
i said hold up you know what i'm saying
month of february and it reads take on
the role of wally a mysterious character
always in motion as you run jump slide
and dash to the soundtrack of data may
sama otherwise known as dan
with the average run time of an action
movie this is a game built for both
speed runners and casual gamers alike so
again salute on the game's a goal so
if you can if you can explain the
process of uh getting never yield on
games of gold and like the joke is is
that games will go back lit continue
uh what you guys need
so uh games to go i appreciate
everything xbox is done um xbox has been
amazing helping me you know get the game
on all the consoles all the platforms so
uh yeah
you know and i i'm super grateful to be
on games with gold it's amazing
um
i don't know what i'm trying to say well
what you're trying to say is not getting
trouble
[Laughter]
well the question is just like the
process like is it something like if you
can like you oh i could say so they came
to you okay nice yeah nice that's what's
up
so they hit me up uh you know hit up my
publisher and was like yo we want to put
you on games to go i was like cool you
know oh
wow that's pretty awesome and again you
know february i think the timing just
was dope too like you know february
obviously it's black history month and
you know to see to see them celebrate
diverse creators and i wanted to ask you
another thing about i guess i'm hearing
about it i don't know if you could tell
me more details on it which is this
diverse creator's fund is that a thing
and it's so like what's that about
yeah there's so many like like you know
not so many but you know there's a
couple uh funds out there that's uh
supporting uh you know people of color
and gaming uh you know they they helped
out uh with me trying to get this uh
game onto different platforms um so uh i
would i tell everybody go check them out
support them so they can support you
know people like me
who want to make these different type of
games
because you know i feel like everybody
plays the same game we're about to talk
about horizon i feel like everyone just
plays the same stuff yeah there's so
many games that come out that uh we we
should all be playing something
different really mm-hmm no i feel you
brother i feel you man diversity
diversity is definitely definitely key
on that stuff and um again you did
release you talk about releasing on all
major platforms and like
you know it's just you bro you don't say
like it's just it's not like this huge
you know studio this whole thing behind
you so like how is your experience with
each platform holder getting you know
sony you're on epic store nintendo
you're on switch i remember when we
first had you back on like people like
yo where's the switch we don't see
switch gang what's happening like so
what was your experience just getting
the game out never yelled out on each
platform
yeah it's it's rough i don't think i'm
gonna do that again all right
so
the the problem with releasing on all
the platforms at once is the fact that
it's really hard to test for all the
platforms at once so you know uh for
anybody looking to do that i would say
just you know pick like two
launch it on there and then come out
like you can see with the update we
launched on uh
pc and xbox first and then you know
playstation another platform coming
later and then after that we're gonna
make sure it's on mobile uh but just
taking taking your time and releasing
slowly so you can kind of address any
bugs as they come rather than trying to
fix everything at once you know it's
real hectic no doubt now i i could
totally understand that and i'm sorry
sorry you're going to jump in yeah i
just want to ask a question about about
development in that because i i'm super
ignorant to how that works
when
is it something when you go from
platform to platform it is a fairly easy
conversion apart from the bug fixing and
the things that are unique so is it
building it from the ground up straight
up for each platform
so it's not building it from the ground
up think of it like um
oh
it's really hard uh
trying to run a program that was built
for your pc on somebody else's pc like
you know it's capable of running but you
know you don't get all these types of
errors when you know you first load it
in with like your drivers and all these
things
so um so like it's like you never know
what the bugs and stuff is going to be
so you kind of just like make that
version of it send it in to
nintendo or whoever and then get the
feedback and say hey you need to
fix this or the frame rate drops here
you need to fix that because we want to
run real smooth like the platforms are
super helpful when it comes to that
stuff it's just like it's hard to
predict
uh what's going to go wrong and you it's
pretty much custom to each uh platform
right now
okay and then that's a good question
you say that okay i'm sorry no go what
makes me wonder how games even release
yeah if they call you tell you hey the
frame rate is dropping here like what
the
hey i mean that treatment was overall
like
do you feel like since you've done it
one time
well you know if you make it another
game it would be easy for you to do it
again because you have a little bit more
information on the matter he said no
because if
yeah yeah the game the game will be
different it'll be different code
different mechanic or whatever um
with this update that i just pushed out
it would have been out two months ago if
it wasn't for leaderboards because all
the platforms handle your boards
differently and it just kind of put a
monkey wrench in the whole thing but uh
yeah it's it's it's a per game uh per
bill type of thing gotcha uh
i don't know how bungie pulls it off
that's that's
crazy
when they tell you issues do they tell
you hey try this to fix it or they just
point out the issue that's it they they
point out the issue um you know they
they don't they don't have the time to
kind of yeah hold your play testing for
me yeah right so uh you know that's why
bugs still slip through right especially
on my end with it they they you know
tell me the the major things that you
know they having trouble with and then i
try to address them
so so in reference to that like because
again there's so much the complexity of
making a video game and then i guess
getting it to certification so let's
just say like i said the bugs
they're not you know baby just made just
made aware of okay there's some issues
with leaderboards or something like that
it comes back to you then like what's
that submission process like the period
between now you resubmit quote unquote
fixed bug leaderboard to the point now
when the game actually gets released on
the platform
it's a while it's a while it's different
like again it's different for a game per
game per you know update whatever
um per issue
uh so it could it could be like you know
a couple days it could be like a month
you know it's it's up there that's why
you got to get it right
uh the first time and kind of you know
use that experience that you have to
kind of know what's going to go right
and what's going to go wrong no doubt
shout out to slow mo he said bungie got
800 people that's how they pull it off
man
that's a good one one stop shop you
already know so one thing i got to
respect about you bro is that like
just seeing someone's like soft seeing
someone like dream come to fruition like
we literally had him in the room was it
two years ago bro like it's like two
choices
something crazy yeah i can't believe
it's been that long and you know we we
kind of you know you were speaking your
dream into reality you were at the time
literally saying yo
this was my last attempt at this you was
like i'm trying to do this and you know
if it don't go down it is what it is i
did what i had to do and keep it pushing
but i love that you say yo
this one i'm going to do it my way it's
going to be as much hip hop is going to
be you know what i'm saying for the
coaches the stuff that i love like i
love that you're with that approach so
my question is like now that you're kind
of living the first step of this dream
and it's kind of well received you know
what i'm saying you got people behind
you like hey all right you know but
listen for your first joint for your
first real joy into the scene like it's
it's it's a lane and my question to you
is just like for the future is it
something now
where it's okay is more updates planned
for never yield or is it something like
okay i got all the feedback i learned
and maybe i got a got a sequel cooking
up or maybe you go another direct like
what what can we get the inside on the
future what's the mindset right now
so yeah
like i said last you know last time it's
really up to the people like uh if
people really feeling it and they come
out you know and support it and you know
back it like that you know i don't think
i have a choice but to kind of you know
work on something in addition to it but
for right now i think you know never
yield you know is good i'm uh i'm going
to start working on other stuff okay uh
different like i don't like making the
same thing over and over again i don't
want to be the hey the black runner guy
the black you know
different characters different you know
something like real different so like if
you feeling like like if you if you like
never yield a lot you know you might not
like my next game okay uh that kind of
difference gotcha you know
my favorite i think you don't got to be
pigeonholed you don't get a visual okay
so you're going to jump in real quick
i'll be adding i see i'm sorry i heard
that no go ahead go ahead first
um i didn't i don't really have any
other questions besides the question
about the uh development
what specifically about development no
it was just asking you know what the
type of experience you have could it
make doing it again a little easier that
was really good
i mean you know making games in general
the more you do do it the more you get
used to it uh and the
making games is just annoying it's like
super annoying um and once you get used
to that level of annoying uh you know
it gets easier
solving is going to jump in
yeah um
one of the things i always really
appreciate about you is how sort of your
candor when it comes to
your feelings on on people of color in
the in the games industry and and kind
of the treatment and
and just kind of
i want to get your take on the last two
years obviously people are are seeing
your game you've gotten good feedback on
the game the game has been you know on
on platforms people are talking about
the game i wonder if what has your
experience been in term in regard to
that have you seen
things improve in the game industry in
terms of taking uh creators of color and
and and their works and sort of pushing
it to the forefront
yeah uh so so the the me being
me saying you know the stuff that i'm
able to say it's purely because i don't
like have a studio i don't have people
working for me um and wish that i have
to also kind of speak for them as well
uh like that the words that i use are
strictly you know my words they're not
backed by you know there's no
consequences for other people right so
that's why other people in the game
industry uh even though they might feel
the same way i feel they might not be
able to say it like how i say it um and
a you know
more power to them they they doing the
best they can yeah um
but as far as uh things getting better
uh i think the numbers are getting
better um but i mean i there's still so
much stuff to do you can see even this
moth um they're like i'm like the only
black
game is
coming out even though i'm just update
but um
you know you you would think there would
be more black characters coming out uh
you see how fans talk about def loop and
how they talk about miles and stuff like
that and how like kind of weird it is
um and just like the fact that you don't
see a lot of black game developers out
there outside of february um being
supported and talked about
um
so when when we get to the point where
no one notices it anymore when
everything just seems like oh there's
always black people in everything
you know i think things would really be
better um there's a lot been said right
now but we're just kind of waiting to
see if you know actions back that stuff
up um
yeah i mean that's something that talks
about all the time where there's some
you know
that that have made real concerted
efforts to to understand people and
cultures that they you know did not grow
up around or understand you know and
that's that's real to me because that's
one of those things like you know i'm
not going to hold it against you that
you don't know who i am or where i come
from or what i've been through because
that's that hasn't been your life but
obviously we have to take the time out
to to understand one another and have
those conversations and have that sort
of empathy for one another and sometimes
you know people do it just for like you
said february comes and goes and you
know something and then the hashtags are
over hashtag black game dev is over
after february exactly we don't see him
no more okay i got you
exactly exactly see you next year see
you next time
see you next february real quick real
quick so there was a comment that just
came in that says just be good at your
job being good at your job has nothing
to do with it facts like i may never
yield uh like more than half the game by
myself um i've i've been this good and i
couldn't get a job for 10 years
um i'm i'm getting offers and stuff now
but like it has never been like this so
like there we've lost so many people who
have been way better than me um just
because they got bills to pay they got
kids they couldn't keep trying to chase
this
um so i just wanted like people to keep
kind of keep that in mind when they
think of that to say hey the best people
will get the jobs and that's never been
the case i'm glad you said that and i
think what it is is first of all
powerful point and i think also what it
is is
i just think not to get preachy but i
just feel like diverse voices makes the
industry better right because it's like
you get to see a culture or something
that you may not be familiar i don't
care what culture you're from you know
saying like if you get to see something
that's underrepresented and now it's out
there it feels brand new it's like a
sparkle like you're like oh okay because
to your point um lord aaron it's like i
get tired of the samey old games all the
time like the same template the same
kind of thing and all that other stuff
it's just like look at the end of the
day we got to be really cognizant of
seeing other cultures other people and
there's nothing wrong with that you know
what i'm saying and there's nothing i
don't understand why there's this
vitriol you know
about about saying it like why is it a
problem for say like yo we like to see
more that hey we like to see you know
we're going to talk about horizon for
ben and wes and you know we like to see
represent the representation that's in
there and then we've had conversations
even about you know curly hair and
texture you know i'm saying that it's
accurate and representation of people of
color and stuff like that and it's just
we just got to get out of that and i
love that you said that because it's not
it's not easy man it really is and we
got to celebrate it as much as we can
but salute on that joint
you know what i'm saying so we got that
we got any other questions before we
wrap up into these topics go ahead kiss
move yeah i just got one more question
because i like i noticed that i don't
know if it was yeah i'm almost certain
almost certain had to be uh this month
it was earlier in the month they uh on
the xbox store because i i frequently
you know check it see what's going on
they have different you know promotions
and they were promoting like
black um not just black development but
anything that had either a black lead or
a uh black characters and i remember
seeing your game being like within like
the first you guys was like oh this is a
nice game i want to know if like
situations like that when they put that
on like a major storefront is that did
you see any impact on that and did you
see an uptick in people trying out your
game or engage a higher engagement when
that promotion went on because i do
remember recall the promotion going i
was like but damn i can't buy the game
again
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so but like i do but it was i saw it
next to uh
the gunk and a few other games that were
there but i was like your game obviously
stood out because we had to interview i
played the game i like i played the crap
out of it and um now i'm about to play
it more because now my achievement
numbers are off so
but uh but yeah i just wanted to know
what was your take and how did that
impact the game and did you see any
changes and and do you uh how do you
feel about it i don't know if other
publisher has done it because i've only
been on the xbox store and seen it um
if your feedback uh to any other
publishers you know doing that that have
storefronts to highlight your game in
that way
yeah like bring like all the storefronts
uh the platforms i mean have kind of
like done you know something um and yes
it's definitely like kind of got eyes on
the game got people like playing the
demo and like kind of looking into it um
and supporting the game
but there's so many black game devs and
black games if that have come out over
the past two years um i appreciate all
the juice that i kind of got from this
but uh i i kind of take all the
opportunities i can to say all right
thanks thanks for kind of like looking
at me and my game but use me as an
example that there are so many other
cool people who make who way better than
me like i'm not even just saying that to
kind of be humble or whatever they just
like generally better like developers
than i am who make games and who get
ignored i kind of was just like in the
right space in the right time with the
right music with the right trailer yeah
and got and got a lot of shine
uh but i i just don't want those people
to be kind of like overlooked or just me
to be that you know post support that
everybody looks at now respect respect
and it's it's about pulling everybody
forward and acknowledging that and that
that's very not only humble of you but
just big picture of you right to look at
the whole landscape and see what's going
on and and know it the mission is bigger
right and that's what it's about they
can give me a job
to come up
i'm so glad you said because that's what
i'll be on like it's like the same thing
with iop and i was like yo we could all
win together we ain't got ain't got to
be just one you know since dude that's
the champion at the post play only he
eat nah everybody can eat like we it's
all good so i'm glad you said that but
uh yo man again congratulations love to
see it continue looking forward with the
next project i gotta follow up with your
top five from uh last time you here last
time you had no more heroes
you had inside
you had last of us
you had which was interesting you had
assassin's
creed black flag dlc
and then you had smash brothers has that
changed your top five rep replace smash
brothers with default all right
okay i'm updating i'm updating i'm
updating my notes
def loops in there maddie plays i'm
sorry see people like that flute body
play anyway so we got that it's amazing
man oh i'm gonna try it when they hit
that game
so in the favorite console of all time
at the time
you have ps4 does that remain ps4 does
anything change
no yeah ps4
i see that hoodie so let's take care of
us
man
i appreciate all the love y'all y'all
keep showing me y'all been showing me
since day one you know with all the
tweets and the support y'all just really
be out here like looking out for people
and you know ain't no words for how much
i uh appreciate it um i also can't wait
to talk about some of these topics
we're about to go there we're about to
go there so let's get the super chats
that we're going to transition right
into these topics
hold on a second let me scroll back a
little bit no doubt no doubt while
that's going on
see what's up realm i see y'all in there
no doubt forte i see what's going on
yeah you want that ray team i know i
know day one we already know what it is
it's a little gas going wow yeah they
going loose they loose you know what i'm
saying
i'm ready
you ready go for it yeah yeah uh we have
slow-mo back slap 10 super chat shout
out to the best game soundtrack of 2021
getting even better what's up lord
smoove and neil i'm down to run through
the game again it was definitely fun
better than playing destiny again
wow
there we go it makes more sense oh there
you go thank you i appreciate that
savage
then we got hollywood rules five dollars
for chat packing to move into my first
home leaving brooklyn going upstate
listening to my boys on iop sunday
thanks for keeping me company best
gaming podcast shout out and
congratulations to you sir yeah getting
out of the bk going out to the boonies
up this beautiful thing
then we got pragmatic eagle five dollars
per chat music is dope and the addition
of the story makes it interesting for me
never cared for runners before i enjoy
this game due to those factors salute
and we got the homie dragon heart yobe
tv five dollar super chat ariel night
let's go hashtag peace love life my
brother thank you for changing the world
one gamer at a time mm-hmm
and we got gaming
then we got gaming forte five dollars
per chat 61 bounties stacked on each
guardians with max shards max prisms
needless to say i love this game also
for the tradition hey lords boo boo
hey
that's it we're caught up all right no
doubt no doubt so we got to get into it
while we're doing that we did have a
poll and there's just cake here at that
when um
microsoft uh recently stated they will
continue to make call of duty and other
popular activision blizzard titles
available on playstation which other
popular activision blizzard game do you
think will also remain multi-platform
the winner of the four-way iop poll at
50 of the vote and for the first time in
a long time
was the messy lords i don't care
we all know the feds is parked outside
redmond campus right now
coveted at second place at 25 percent of
the vote was both diablo and overwatch
will be multiplied group coming in at
third place at 22 percent of the vote
was overwatch and in last place and only
two percent of the vote was just diablo
so salute to all the lords who uh
wrapped in there lord solve you know uh
what's going on man what were we
thinking i think the blessing lawyers
got it right man you know they gotta
come out there you know handle these
things preemptively you know what i mean
clean you know clean out the coffers a
little bit make sure everything is right
oh it's just funny to me because
they have to do this because of the
optics but again like we've spoke about
in the past like when it comes to if you
really look at
where this pl places them in the power
hierarchy they're still number three and
they don't have as many studios as as
one and two put together so in that
regard
it isn't a monopoly now when you start
talking about the underlying things that
they do in terms of internet
infrastructure azure stuff like that and
what how that can be consolidated that's
kind of where they they have to worry a
little bit but in terms of like the pure
optics of hey you just bought this big
publisher
it still doesn't put them really i think
in anybody's sites but again
they've gotten away in the past with
things that they probably should not
have
and you know revenge is the revenge is
there people that just want to see
microsoft not do well and not be able to
get the things they want so
um yeah so it's going to be interesting
but i think i think they're right about
that hey just let's make sure we get
button this up before you know yeah
before they come knocking on the door
you know
outside man you got to make sure
sometimes concessions need to be made
you guys see what's going on what was it
a head of regulation a head of
regulation that's what you know
why
let's get into it y'all one of the major
topics this is saab's topic a big
release has dropped horizon forbidden
west for playstation before you get into
your impressions i want to salute who
has come through the back door another
one out of iron lord family my man lord
ms babbitt how are we doing sir
uh i've been playing nothing but this
game i don't even know
though
busy weekend though glad you could join
cause we want as much information as we
can but we gotta start off with solve
man i mean this is you this is your
topic uh how much have you played what's
the impressions what's the vibe before
we open this thing up man so i'm glad we
have we have smoove and bad bit on
because um
we uh i know they've played considerably
more than me i just have about eight
hours from last night so i was i was
blazing last night but i like i said
earlier on i haven't even hit the
forbidden west yet right so i haven't
seen the full-on open world as of yet
so i don't know if you guys remember but
my impressions of of zero dawn were a
little bit okay they were a little bit
tainted by breath of the wild right they
definitely were i i can't say that they
weren't
um because they were two open world
games that came out in very close
proximity to one another and one of them
did some some stuff that i i felt was
really revolutionary and the other one
didn't
um so i fell off of zero dawn and
originally like very
after after zelda came out it was a wrap
for zero dawn for like another year and
then i finally went back and i still
wasn't enamored with the with the open
world
um but the story really grabbed me and
and and alaway as a character really
grabbed me so going into this i was
excited to see
what kind of improvements and changes
they made to the open world and
obviously where the story was going to
go and where ayloy was going to progress
as a character
so jumping into me the first thing you
notice immediately is
wow
it is a beautiful game i i jump back and
forth between performance mode and
graphics mode just to see but when
you've been playing in performance mode
so long
once you go back to the 30 fps mode you
see the resolution right you see the 4k
resolution but it feels choppy until
your eyes kind of adjust sounds like i'm
going back to performance mode it still
looks great it runs beautifully so i've
been playing on that the game is
absolutely gorgeous um
the color palette um
so far
there's a lot of browns and reds and
like deep greens and and that's a lot of
what you see in the beginning of the
game much like zero dawn
um but i but i've seen pictures
unfortunately i didn't want to see
anything but i've seen pictures of more
diverse sort of biomes they kind of take
more advantage of the expanded palette
so i'm excited to see that so
initially my my impressions in that
beginning part of the uh the game
were that this is a lot more this is
just more zero dawn with a w with you
know obviously looking much much
prettier and with
some additions to traversal and things
like that but it didn't feel like a huge
departure and as of yet it still doesn't
feel like a huge departure um so i'm
excited to see what comes in the open
world and how that changes for me um i'm
enjoying eloy as a character as i did
before i think uh you know she's she can
be a little she she is about her
business and she doesn't want anybody
she doesn't want anybody's help she
doesn't she's like i have to do this by
myself and when she gets
very independent it's very much like
she's burdened herself with this and she
doesn't
she doesn't want to endanger anyone else
so she's that type of hero character
right so a white savior type of hero
my lord
he went there
but i
i
you know what that was funny about that
ariel is is the fact that i i want them
to do
what they what they did to ellie right i
want them to take her and drag her
through the dirt a little bit and make
her sort of make difficult decisions um
because i think that would make her even
more interesting but yeah she is super
heroic kind of unflinching batman-esque
i don't budge like in that way okay
which i can see me i can see in the
long-term making her a little boring but
as of now you know the hero character i
think she's fine i do like how she
speaks her quips i like how she
interacts with with with the npcs she's
she's very well acted
um
when it comes to things that again felt
samey to me or or just kind of weird is
that again i hate making the comparison
but the comparison is still there oh
there are things that they've done to
sort of zeldify
the traversal a little bit
this is where they come for you this is
where they come you jay bar was on and
you talk about traversal you talk about
breath of the wild and this is where
they get mad with you continue it is the
truth again it's removed from breath of
the wild right but at the same time the
things that they kind of did to sort of
go in that direction mm-hmm
i feel don't make a whole lot of sense
and and kind of they're not
this they're not as good as the
solutions that breath of wild or even
assassin's creed has made for like
traversal and stuff like that if if i
can if i can here come
here
he was holding back because i'd be
listening to badminton i know he hold it
all right now for
continue no no no
like i think you've made excellent
points so far because like if people are
expecting you know if if you did not
like the combat in horizon one and
you're expecting that to suddenly change
drastically it's not it's more horizon
it's more horizontal um
but when it comes to the traversal
elements or the open world um i was
actually just thinking about it right
before we came on if ghost of tsushima
is the equivalent to
its inspirations of breath of the wild
right in terms of like its dynamic world
you're getting distracted whether it's a
bird or a fox in your way type of deal
um then this kind of to me feels like
they're witcher 3
where you have these hub world open
areas
um that it's about it's deep
storytelling it's not just comparing
what you're three to horizon forbidden
way i just did absolutely did uh so hold
your turn hold the line
let everybody get the points off yeah
just just because like if you take a
look at which or three in it in the way
it tells its story through its open
world
a great example is in not well actually
a great example is their white orchard
area
uh where you first start up the was it
the
jerk or the dredge or whatever that's
kind of like their their white orchard
where it's like hey this is the world
this is what it's going to be this is
what you can expect here are some side
quests
and then the world kind of tells the
story around you so like you'll have a
couple of you know soldiers that are
injured out somewhere in this
battlefield and you'll have the cause of
that violence which is these machines
are these bandits around you similar to
like that of you know the witcher 3
where you have this battle that just
happened and then a little while away
you have these civilians that are just
trying to escape
via that bridge and those you know
soldiers that won't let them pass that
type of storytelling that they're trying
to go for is it one to one is it exact
no but that's how i kind of see it right
it is how i interpret it right like
their inspiration it doesn't when i say
it's like because those are like easy
terms right it's not saying that this is
a one-to-one this is just saying
there's inspiration here and and it's
generally improved in that way yeah yeah
okay so
i believe i just want to focus back on
the traversal part because it seems like
you had is this specific with climbing
like the animation of like specifically
okay for climbing so climbing the
animations are great but what they do is
you you kind of you click with your
focus right to show you the climbing
routes right and they're varied like
there's there's a part early on like i
said right before you get to the i
forgot what the words called uh
uh
i forgot the name but it's it's before
you get into the forbidden words per se
it's when you go to the uh the embassy
and
right before that there's a there's a
thing you have to climb and you can find
an old cargo tower and you click on your
focus and it shows you all the climbing
routes sort of in yellow right right
yeah so i'm like okay
i look at that and i'm like okay
when you're doing it it feels more
varied right if you're playing the game
and you it feels more varied you can go
everywhere
i just don't understand the design the
design decision to do give you like go
in and create these bespoke routes
as opposed to
because the climbing isn't necessarily i
wouldn't say necessarily difficult at
least at this point i don't know if
there's more climbing centric puzzles
later on that make the climbing more of
a
more of just something that's not
happenstance if that is the case then i
can see this but i don't i look at this
and i'm like why don't they just follow
the assassin's creed rod where you could
just when you run up on something you
you climb on it right
and it feels more organic in that way
right
rather than hey i gotta look at this i'm
looking at this this route up like a
predetermined route a predetermined
route that i don't think
for me
comparing it to those other games and
again
i hate to do it
but when it's it's for a game that i
really want to lose myself in and feel
as organically in that world as possible
that was like a little bit disappointing
to me like damn like just just do the
climbing and again that's me i don't
know what
just do the traveling do that do the hit
the button
exactly so it's me as me as a dumb fan
saying why don't you do this okay
but uh that's fair that's fine but
that's fair but apart from that apart
from that i am excited to see because
that's one thing i did hear that uh that
that
badly was talking about is the this idea
that they took the
learnings from the witcher 3
and these games that
have so much environmental storytelling
and where the side stories actually
double back onto the main story in
interesting ways um you know i i think
of witcher 3 and i think of bloody baron
and what the bloody baron sort of meant
for side stories in general side side
quest in the game i'm like wow like
literally i want to go to every question
mark this on this yeah i heard these
side quests are crazy right yeah so for
me
as somebody again even with ghosts of
sushima they did a lot more organic
things in the open world to sort of help
you traverse it and make it feel more
alive
it still fell into those tropes
that open world games do where the
repetition of the activities and stuff
like that and i don't know if this will
do the same
but again i i i'm excited to to be
proven wrong in that regard because
again for me though the standards in
that regard still are obviously breath
of the wild for the sense of discovery
and organic nature of the world
and which are for
for how
dense the world feels right everything
feels like it like it belongs there and
it's lived in and you could say what you
want about the bloat included in in
these assassins creed open worlds right
but those worlds are meticulously
created and in a lot of ways they really
do feel lived in you they're not there
with the side stories they've gotten
better with the characters with with
like cassandra and stuff like that in in
assassin's creed odyssey and stuff like
that but they still have a ways to go in
terms of making that world feel as lived
in as as a witcher 3
but it's something about those worlds
and that historical sort of setting that
really feels like they they put a lot of
time and effort into that and that's
what i want to feel in horizon that i
didn't feel in the first one i felt it
was a cool world hey a robot dinosaurs
and what drove it for me was eloy as a
character and her story which is bonkers
and and but the open world didn't do it
for me and i'm hoping it does it for me
in this one but so far so good like so
far
because again where i am it still very
much feels like hey this is more zero
dawn i haven't seen the forbidden west
where everybody's saying that's the true
open world that's where it really shows
you early doing new all right yeah so
but i'm excited to to to get there no
doubt let's open it up let's get let's
get aerial nights yeah real quick let's
go no i was practicing it to you right
now it's you i gotta i just got my my
quick little hot take
let's go because because i i play um
horizon uh the first one okay um and i
was like i was ready for it you know
when the game like first launched those
trailers i was like i'm all in i'm
excited about this um
but it's it's her story i can't stand
her story
and like uh the the white savior thing
bugs me just like beyond measure people
like you got so many diverse characters
in this world and then she's just kind
of plopped into it i get why people like
it but uh i think people don't get why i
don't like it
that's just your opinion
horizon both of them like i'm gonna play
this uh new one more uh just not right
now uh because i want to play other
stuff but um
the i think with the core of my the
stain for it is the fact that i i love
that world so much but the main
character i just don't like you just
don't connect with the main character i
mean it's games like that i mean it's
not no i i understand what you can
connect with her i i can't connect with
her
i feel like she doesn't want me to
connect with her
no she she doesn't want like she doesn't
want she doesn't want anybody to connect
with her really that's correct like i
think i think butter toast is more
interesting than avalor oh my god we're
gonna thank god i got bad bitter here
continue good continue guys
let's open it up to a kiss boom kayla's
next no like like so like
the first game like there was things
that i loved about the first game
um zero dawn like i said the only thing
that beat it out for game of the year
for me was assassin's creed origins for
obvious reasons but zero zero dawn the
thing was like i enjoyed the world i
enjoyed like the concept of like these
uh robotic animals and it was yeah all
out beautiful but i could not stand aloy
i didn't like the standoffish robotic
attitude
and it may be like she got all soul
tours yeah
it was emotionless it was like am i
saying that right it was like
emotionless so with this game i was like
all right let's go into forbidden west i
know they improved like the facial
animations maybe she won't look as
robotic or just like kind of just weird
when you're looking at her respond to
things but like she's still pretty much
bullish right and they got these new
amazing character well they're not they
just look improved because you know
texture upgrades and stuff like that you
got var overall looking crazy out there
yeah they they got these characters and
stuff so like uh
i think me and um
um saw um sovereign are around the same
box i did not break through the um
the forbidden yes i didn't get past the
nbc yet i got to the point where they
deny you and you can force your way
through but i was like you know what
let me just clean up every side mission
here before i leave because i don't know
what's going to happen once i go here is
it going to be a problem getting back or
so i was like let me just clean it up
but
based off what i played so far
it seems like an advanced version
of xerodon currently but i can't speak
to what like bad bit may say because
he's probably obviously further out
but the thing is despite my uh
this dislike for like certain elements
about zero down like i thought the last
boss battle was whack and like i said
not me came for a loy this game
i'm having all the same things i love
about the world the graphics uh the the
combat is even to as early as i am is
much improved and whatnot and so that's
what makes me want to um play more
because i know once the world opens up
and i unlock more get more equipment the
the combat's going to be even much
better
um
but yeah it's like
i i'm invested i'm like invested i'm not
like i didn't drop the uh the last game
i'm i'm to the point where i'm invested
i'm curious to see how things play out
and those side missions are extremely
quality now i've never played i can't
say i never play i never finished the
wish you think i dropped the witcher
through like a bad conversation
so like i like there's several games i
put above the witcher 3 in terms of
similar action rpg likes
horizon zero dawn is one of them um but
the side missions in this game are ready
i'm like wait am i part of a main quest
or is the side quest that's how good
they've been so far and they're they're
proven to be very very valuable because
i've gotten some things that
i i feel like i would need
to move forward but they came from side
missions right not afraid of let me give
it to you baby before we do that let me
just address something in the chat all
right first of all y'all we got to be
respectful you know everybody's got
their own takes their own opinions here
on this panel and in the chat where you
are going to lose me and where the mods
gonna get you is when y'all start with
the personal attacks please do not
personalize it if you personalize it i'm
getting you out of here again respect
people's opinion that are different from
yours you don't have to agree but don't
be disrespectful that's all i'm saying
let's continue
look look at how we doing sir what's
going on what how far are you in this
game
um
god i don't know time's an enigma at
this point but i've
i've gone to a lot of
you know walking in
horizon i loved it it was my game of the
year
um it's a reason why the trophy room
exists all that good stuff
and so i i love this game i love a-loi
it appears that's the hottest steak here
um i like her character she's curious uh
and i like that curious nature about her
and the sequel she is way more yeah
she's got she's got stuff to do and it's
not like the like i'm an independent
woman i don't need no man type of thing
it's more like
uh the world
the
the fate of the world is on my shoulders
right and i can't bear that burden on
anyone else
so i must burn it alone
anybody with that has like bad anxiety
has that feeling um so to me i i like
that arc that she's going on because
right now yeah there's
it's hard to
relate to her but i understand that's
part of the arc in the in the characters
that are growing alongside her because
in the original game yeah like i i
forgot who varl is yeah i i called aaron
aaron
you know
those characters were extremely
forgettable it was all about alloy but
for
for this
you know game it seems like the story is
if we if we got if you're doing it we're
doing it right um it's kind of like the
fellowship of the ring type of deal so i
i really love the arc that she's on
because i know at the end
of this arc i'm going to get a more
refined character
um and i've already seen beats of that
so like
those little pieces of armor are gonna
wear away as time goes on
um and shout out to the side missions
because yeah they are
excellent man like
far more memorable than
i
thought they were going to be and yeah
they're again this game is you know
we're going to say witcher 3 a lot
because
there's no way you're making an open
world game at this point and you're not
being inspired by either witcher brother
wild in some form or fashion
but it really does take a lot of those
hey side quests don't have to be just
fetch quests they can actually help
define the world
around you and actually build upon the
world and those stories i feel
are absolutely terrific and yeah they
fool me because like there's like a
question they'll be like five six quests
long and i'm just like this character is
important and hopefully i see them again
because i actually really
really dig them
um
and yeah like shout out to the refined
support characters yeah as well like
varl is my favorite character like
midway through i'm like dude i want a
game with varl like i want a game with
him that he see there's like there's a
there's a portion of this world that i
think could could do with do with his
like weapon set he's awesome and even
aaron like
you're seeing everybody deal with the
events of the first game in their own
different ways and how eloy has
effectively abandoned them
and so like you're seeing that firsthand
in these characters and so that
resentment that like audiences may hold
for eloy for being tough
or or whatever or callous
the side characters you're you're in
their perspective because they're like
why are you doing this stuff like we're
we just showed you we could do this
together why are you pushing us away so
i really i really dig the story in that
aspect there are some twists and turns
that i'm down with i'm down with i don't
know if everyone's going to be down with
some of the decisions that they do i'm
always i'm always down for them to blow
up with what you expect to happen yeah i
100 like it's not a golf club situation
but it is like uh okay you've been with
us with the robot your ass because we're
about to
we're about to up the ante a little bit
um but yeah like the open world is
stunning i i love it i see a lot of
you know
what i love about death stranding in
this game like the traversal elements
you can see
where they've taken from kojima and
placed in this game um it's it's awesome
i like when you're scanning the the the
areas where to go i i dig that because
it's it's like the little robot and dust
stranding so you're seeing the x's where
you can't go you're seeing the crosses
where you can they're like okay i could
maneuver around here to get there um and
last but not least the combat is still
awesome like there is so much they've
expanded it so much so where you have
all these different trees of all these
different ultimate abilities that are
going to help alloy out
depending on the situation at hand so
there's going to be trees that are great
at melee combat and they actually build
upon the melee combat they give you
combos and all that stuff
to help with like fighting human enemies
you have you know just basic range skill
your infiltrator all that good stuff to
kind of define alloy out even more in
the combat so
if you are the type of person that's
like i'm just gonna go whack you know
crap with my spear yeah
there's a tree for you there if you're
mainly glass cannon ranged you can you
can fill that tree out there or if you
want a little bit of everything you
could do that as well so
there's a lot to this game man this game
is huge i can understand why it took so
long is it going to be
one of the greatest
you know
rpgs of our time no i think like witcher
3 is still going to hold that crown i
think it's that's a tremendous game
uh but this this is no slouch whatsoever
i i really
really dig it and i came in coming in
going i'm gonna really like this game a
lot and
walking out it's met my expectations
i know like i said we kind of have tough
business decisions to make as far as
what games we could play and not play so
uh where you at i mean i know you're
thinking about kind of doing because you
got a lot of stuff going on with your
review schedule but like based on what
you're hearing based on what you're
seeing about it is it something that
interests you
uh
i'll be real with you man no
really i i try to play that first one so
many times like i tried to play it again
at the end of this week nothing grabs me
nothing about the interest story grabs
me nothing about the characters grammy a
loy i people said in the chat she's a
karen i wouldn't go that far but it's
just like
she just got no emotion to her like and
what's funny is like she's inconsistent
she was supposed to be isolated her
whole life but she has all these uh
these social skills like i i just i
never understood anything about that
game and uh first off i don't like games
that rely on bow
combat combat
primary like
it's just like if your only ability true
ability is that you could shoot a bow
which is which is a fantastic ability
but it's just like i i always felt like
see i like being in people's face that's
what i like to do so if you make me play
a game both landing me shoot this bow
over and over again i'm not gonna like
it as much like sure like when i played
uh zelda i rarely used his bow ever if
any
i used it when a temple made me use it
that's pretty much about all and it's
just like
that i just didn't like it and i tried
the first one multiple times and it's
just it didn't hit me i didn't like any
of the characters uh it's just
i liked more in the first hour of ghost
fusuhima than the eight times i tried
horizon because at least i felt
emotional connection with the character
off the off the back people could say oh
it's because it's a female it has
nothing to do with it when i see when i
i did play a little bit of rise of the
two mirror because the kids move right i
enjoyed when i played that i felt
emotional
attitude at a lower croft like i don't
feel that at all i feel like she's
literally a robot
let me ask you this that's not the
country so i get it with the first game
i get where you where you going my
question is now with what you have seen
with the second game with supposedly
more improved even melee combat that
type of skills tree and apparently like
what you know what saab is saying with
um babbitt is saying it and in the
emotionality of the character kind of
coming forth a little bit more none of
this even appeals you say you know what
let me try to see this time maybe this
time it might connect
well first off i don't play like direct
sequels that have story related stuff
from the original one unless i played
the first considering i can't get
through the first two hours of the
original one i'm definitely not gonna
play the second one but like i'm not i'm
not into the into the standpoint where
it's like
i think they have to change stuff people
keep saying in the chat oh you know they
didn't do anything different
if you liked horizon and you're a fan of
horizon why would i try to take that
experience from you in the sequel
i've always been the the
behind the the fact that as long as you
improve mechanics and introduce new
mechanics we don't need to make the
sequel something different
like i i hate that mentality you know
even me and solve is argued about when
it comes to gears it's like look the
formula works well the fans love it so
just keep doing it but do it better the
next time i'm not like look i don't like
horizon
that's cool but i'm not really the
target demographic of that like i don't
like the bo stuff you can you miss me
with that so that's cool that's that's
all that's all everyone else man that's
all everyone else it's just like when it
comes to me i like emotion and stuff and
sure i'm sure she has emotion in the
game yeah cause i'm like the way you
acting like [ __ ] you just run around
with what you face but i play two and a
half hours a game and i don't feel none
of that but that was the first game
the story to me in the first one really
is awesome
yeah i don't you know forget about the
gameplay and then maybe jump in from
there
look man
hey you already know it's over once you
get to look bad it's over here
you see this little see this little
yellow
i did i tried the first one i literally
just played it again you could ask i
tried
to try to get through this game and i
have been very adamant if i'm wrong i
come i did with skyward sword i said i
was wrong about that game yeah you're
right it's just this game does not
resonate with you same thing with your
three for that i played that game i i
played a lot more of the witcher i think
the witcher's a little bit more on
something when it comes to the game's
just so massive i come back like two
weeks later and i forgot what i've been
doing and i restarted so i start
restarting it i'm not restarting it
again
but it's just like
i i could see why people like horizon
it's just not for me
fair enough there is actually a cool a
cool aspect of the story that you
reminded me of uh she there is like a uh
uh in the first game she's an outcast
and she's so desperate to
be
yeah
and now like everybody kind of hails her
as a god status and she's just openly
bewildered by that concept like it and
like even almost like that sometimes
it's your face
is kind of like yeah no real talk she's
like she's insulted by it almost it's
like oh really i've been outcast but now
i'm
okay
like she's she's unsettled by it i mean
when it comes down to it i love for xbox
to get something on this quality but
it's just like look like i would like
for them to use a different character
than alloy but you know
i just
the games that i'm excited for just
doesn't involve horizon you know see
notice that i wasn't on twitter telling
people not to play horizon because i
don't care if you're playing horizon if
if it's something i think it's pretty
ridiculous that people are complaining
about 89 but we're gonna get to it we're
gonna get to it
it's just like look at the end of the
day
i i will stand on this if you like a
game and you play the sequel i do
understand where people want something
new but people got to be realistic when
it comes to developers because i'm sure
as ariel can attest like
when you consider making something new
it's hard to have a balance on what made
the original what it was and what you
could do to give the perspective of that
game to newer audiences in a sequel
we've seen so many developers tried this
and fell it we see bungie fell from
destiny wanted to they felt it so much
they had to really pretty much do the
entire game over again so it's just like
look like at the end of the day
if you like horizon one
don't [ __ ] about people to change
horizon two to make it
not horizon one that's the only thing i
really wanna look i'll jump in i'm sorry
sorry somebody's gonna say something i
don't know who's you know no that's
right no go ahead no i was just gonna
say like you know for me
i understand addicts frustration i felt
so bad with this situation because i'm
like
this is about to happen to me again with
this franchise
and i was all hyped up when the first
one got launched i saw the trailers i'm
like okay gorilla's doing something
different it didn't kill zone this look
fire the character then i'm like i like
the kind of prehistoric slash futuristic
dinosaur flow i was like okay this is a
unique spin and then this switch came
out
every
you know breath of the wild and i'm like
all the old nintendo hidden fanboy that
i didn't realize i had as the second kid
came out and i saw it climbing and i'm
like i know what i'm doing like i know
what i'm doing so i'm like okay cool but
you know you get back around to it and
then i'm like all right i tried it and
it did i will agree it didn't
catch me for whatever reason it just
emotionally i just didn't connect right
but then also that was during the 30
frames days right so but all right
you gonna come back out ps5
you know 60 frames you know we get back
to you backlog gets crazy and then here
we are again
and i'm like all right
freddie i know it's coming because i was
hoping it hit the first target date
which was what was it bad but it was
like last year was supposed to come out
yeah it was supposed to come out spring
of last year yeah so i'm like oh spring
i'm like okay you know what i'm saying
all year last year wasn't crazy that's
when i want to play you
and then y'all know i'm a destiny guy
and then here come witch queen and i'm
like they doing everything i want to do
and i'm like i know i'm not going to
play it because what's going to happen
is i see how beautiful it is
but i feel it's disrespectful for me to
even attempt the sequel without
finishing the first like i just feel
like this but i just mean but anyway to
the game itself
it looks absolutely gorgeous it looks
absolutely gorgeous i feel like
from everything i've seen gorilla looks
like they are in their bag and it's a
looker as far as next gen you know i
know a lot of racial sensitivity in the
chat today but i do like diversity
in the npcs and showing them you know
how they look and actually that the
characters are are really like not just
kind of like one-offs like how kind of
what babbitt was saying where it's like
you kind of real fully connected you
want to really complete this person's
story and how it affects the overall
thing and it looks like the combat
improved the the casting looks amazing
like angela bassett they got my chick
from the matrix was it carry on
morrisons
yeah you know of course you know zavala
lance reddick my men's you know what i'm
saying
like they really really look like they
went all out and i want to shout them
out and look i am a hashtag just one guy
so i see these type of games and i'm
like i know xbox got some coming i know
they do but it's just like this you
gotta understand like this is
for the people who don't like it right
this is a lot of people who stay in the
sony ecosystem for these games alone and
i sit there and i'm like yo they look
like they got one you know they're like
they say they're popping off right now
but i wanted to ask you this because
it's two parts i want to play because
obviously i didn't play so i have other
questions for y'all that have played it
which is all right so we're seeing some
controversies about bugs
and i want to talk about
the metacritic controversy
and the third thing i want to talk about
shout out to rick hogue there seems to
be a big
uproar about what's something that um
hog brought to your attention as far as
the up charging for the for the ps4
version
in comparison to the ps5 version and
some people saying that it's hidden in
the store and then people are hustling
probably like yo i'm just going to the
app download the ps4 version pay
that 60 dollars and then it gets the
free upgrade so it's i know it's a lot
of questions so bugs metacritic
controversy let's start back with solves
this is your topic
um i haven't experienced any bugs so far
but again like i said i'm and i played
again that initial area like like uh
like smoove was saying there's there's a
lot of side quests and stuff you could
do there's a lot of like running around
the open world and just grabbing like
grabbing medicine and grabbing like wood
to make uh arrows and stuff like that
it's kind of stuff that minutia i like
in open world games so i get lost in
that i didn't see any bugs so far i had
uh i had a big uh boss battle that went
went off without a hitch
i have not seen anything in terms of
bugs like the water looks great and
nothing
nothing nothing has frozen for me
nothing like that so i can't speak to
that metacritic and um charging people
are hot solved they're saying
this should have been a 90 why is it in
80. it's currently sitting in medicaid
at 88. what the hell is wrong with these
people these people all bought off why
can't this thing get a 90. talk to me
okay some people don't understand
averages
[Laughter]
yeah for sure but the more the more
reviews come out right
the average is gonna level off it's just
gonna trend lower no matter what no
matter what unless you get you get you
know the the next 10 reviews are all
tense and that's not going to happen
because that would have happened day one
right so any reviews you have coming
down the pipeline are probably more
middle of the road to lower if if that
that's a thing um
so
just stop caring about the numbers i see
so many people who who bust their tail
writing
in-depth reviews and nobody reads them
and they scroll down to the bottom for
the number and then that's it
and the number at the end of the day
does not mean anything if you're if your
enjoyment is defined by someone else's
number
you got a problem
88.89 i don't care it was a game i was
gonna play anyway if it was a game you
wanted to play you will play unless of
course listen
for me metacritic is very good for
determining
broad
a broad sense of what this game is if
the broads take on the game was a 60
then i say okay cool
read more in depth to see where these
60s are coming from and at that point
it's a decision about whether it's worth
it to spend your money on it but when
you're talking about
points that determine you know a jump
between 89 90 88 and then whatever the
case may be nah it's it's a stupid
argument it's gonna continue to happen
every time a big game comes out and this
happens
and then personally
personally like i said before
i think when we look at the standard
bearers
for open world game slash rpgs
it's still not up there with the
greatest i haven't again i haven't
played a lot of this
so far what i've played
it's more of the last one okay which a
lot of people felt was
in 85 you know what i mean 85 to to
maybe 9 you know
and some people truly love that game
again i don't care about the number but
at the end of the day from what i've
played so far it feels like it's more of
that and again
i will make a determination as i play
more of that game like bad [ __ ] said is
it more witcher 3 right because the
closer you get to that standard to me
that's when i i then that's when the
conversation changes so for me again
just
if you wanted to play this game play the
damn game stop it stop yeah i'm tired of
that now what was the other thing the
third part was all right so basically
there's a lot of different versions of
horizon videos on the store the the
point of continue we got to shout out
the lord of virtual legality he's going
in on this yes and hope rick hogue and
pretty much what has happened is
if you get the ps4 version of horizon
bend west it is 60 right yes um however
with a free upgrade path because
remember they with the cross
generational stuff they made everything
now a free upgrade path but now the ps5
version is 79 what he is saying is that
when you go to the marketplace
it is very more apparent and visible
about the ps5 version and you kind of
got to do a little extra work to find
the ps4 version so the hustle
is people are going you know whether it
be on a mobile app or something out and
download the ps4 to get the ps5 free
upgrade so what his point is is from
dishonest business practice standpoint
because he's saying that they are
literally trying to not make this
information
you know readily present and that has
caused some controversy i just want your
aspect on that and then we're going to
open this up to everybody it was i mean
you got to remember that
it was something that jim ryan had said
initially i guess when
we first talked about the game and
and
it was always supposed to that game was
included in that it was something that
was talked about when they when they
announced the ps5 and i guess i forgot
where exactly it was but it was it was
announced that
launch window games right were still
going to be and then you know the
definition of launch windows we know is
is fluid we don't know what that means
always right so um but the impression
was that
forbidden west is always going to be in
that so
when jim ryan made the statement like no
we're not gonna do it anymore there was
the uproar and then he rolled back he
said okay this is the last one
the reluctance on their part to do that
shows that they were never going to
bring this deal to the forefront right
it was it's imperative upon them to do
it because they promised they would do
it it's not imperative upon them to put
it at the front of the of the shop and
be like yeah do this when they don't
when they really don't want you to do it
let me
quote home right quick because i know
where you're going he goes okay
forbidden restaurant update anyone that
buys a ps4 version well we'll get the 60
okay he says um naturally most customers
have decided that this essentially means
people will buy the ps4 version
regardless of what they own to save ten
dollars the problem as argued by hogue
is that sony appears to be diverting
customers from the ps4 version as much
as possible trying to get people to pay
more for essentially the same product on
the playstation store website whole
notes the ps5 version and its higher
price is displayed prominently at the
top with the ps4 to your plate version
tucked away in the bottom half of the
page the game's fact page contains
out-of-date information telling users
they must buy a special edition to get
both versions of the game which is no
longer the case whole belief these and
other practices related to release of
horizon forbidden west could constitute
as unlawful marketing so that that's the
part that is that is a problem if you
have not changed the language around
that right
on purpose or not caring whatever the
case may be that is a problem
that that is absolutely a problem um
another thing that they did was that if
you got the upgraded version it wasn't
unlocking at midnight it was unlocking
later yeah as well
and hog does as the article continues
shout out to svg.com hope does believe
um that there could be a class-action
lawsuit in sony's future filed by anyone
who feels duped into buying the 70
version of horizon forbidden west while
individual states in the u.s have laws
against deceptive marketing the amount
of money on the line might not be enough
for some lawyers to get involved
ultimately hog argued that sony should
correct by either changing the price of
the ps5 version to 60
or to allow ps5 users to buy the ps5
versions through their console so what
it is on the console side
you can't do it and people are hustling
and going outside the console because of
it to do yeah yeah they said something
about going to the website to have to do
it yeah yeah
yes
again these extra steps that
technically
are
technically on their side i believe they
don't think it's a problem but it is a
problem i mean i i'm gonna tell you
right now i completely forgot about the
upgrade i just bought the 70 dollars
mission accomplished this game
yeah
i'll jump backwards here uh yeah no
they're absolutely lying to you they
absolutely want your extra ten dollars
and they absolutely know that this won't
cause a fuss like
they
if they were truly being was beloved
here
they really would have just lowered the
skew of the playstation 5 version but
when they purposely did not do that
uh
you could see the t leaves a mile away
of like oh no they'll still push the ps5
version of the playstation 4 version
will be somewhere we don't know curtains
up on that one you know whatever um and
and they're going to
weasel their way out of it they're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna save face by
saying the nice thing but they're really
going to screw you over at the end and
that's exactly what happened because
you know
twitter isn't real it's not a real place
it's equitable people get in their
feelings a lot on twitter right and so
what playstation probably wanted to do
is just like hush the noise a bit say
that they're reversing it while just
leaving that skew right there for
the average consumer that isn't on
twitter and is it bickering over
metacritic scores that are just walking
in a game stop buying that sku
and so playstation's still getting that
ten dollars
um they really want that 10 bucks i
what can you do
money it's money yeah it's money so
we got you i got you next i got you next
day so yeah no they definitely that was
a deception that's a lie and ozzy i
don't know if there's going to be a
class action lawsuit because i don't
know how many people actually care yeah
that's about the grand scheme of things
uh that being said when it comes to the
metacritic score i have a firm belief
and i'm going to say this with my whole
chest here let's go um if you post
metacritic pictures on twitter to own
people you are in fact the biggest loser
i've ever seen in my entire life
you're a loser you're pathetic and
honestly i feel bad for you because that
is nice i don't i don't understand that
i don't understand the enjoyment out of
it um i you know my favorite game of all
time is bloodborne it sits out in 92. uh
i'm one of my favorite games ever tied
with that is ghosta sushima i 83. i love
that game it's perfect to me
um
you know i into the spider-verse is my
favorite movie of all time it's not
citizen kane though so you know there
you have to
who cares what color green yellow or red
it is
if it's if it's something you enjoy go
out there experience it play it be your
own critic don't have losers on the
internet dictate what your thoughts are
going to be and when i mean losers i
mean again those people that are
throwing out the metacritic like we
owned the boys are you implying that
people are weaponizing medicare
they'll weaponize everything for
10.
it's so tight it's so tiring where like
every time there's a game it doesn't
matter if it's on playstation nintendo
or xbox whatever
it it's so tiring because you know
everybody's going to go after that
reviewer
i like when they come for the outlet as
if there's the same reviewer reviewing
every game every second okay yeah
and they're like oh this this guy's an
xbox review and you can see by that it's
like no xbox doesn't pay reviewers no
one pays reviewers
no that's that's not real
it's stupid anybody that says that's
also an idiot so like to me i just i
hate the process because i understand
and i know people who work their butts
off to
put out quality reviews like ames right
now is going to be pushing 100 hours
into something i can't say right
now but like he's putting in the work
and if anybody tries to dare say
anything about him because they the
number isn't high or low enough to their
standard you're an idiot you're just
that's it i i don't i don't like that
type of
thought pattern
i i i absolutely hate it you know
developers shouldn't be attacked because
they're reusing an animation reviewers
shouldn't be attacked because they have
an opinion that's opposite of yours
so to me
look i was gonna get this game
regardless i i don't i don't care um
metacritic should be used as a gauge of
like okay if it's in the yellow maybe i
need to like solve said
read more into it but the way i look at
it is go to the places and the people
that you know you're going to align with
that's right that that that reviewer
fits yeah yeah that fits your your your
criteria of what you're like like great
great example skilled up i know if
skilled up is going to like something
we'll have the same taste in things
i'm going to genuinely trust his word
more than most and so i'll go to him but
like i'm not going to like
xbot
420xxx for my in-depth analysis of of
horizon or literally anything um you
know i'm not going to go to the guy with
the phil spencer emoji in this
screen he's out of control salute to you
brother i understand it chose violence
no you told him you clearly chose
violence you know
likewise i'm not gonna do the i'm not
gonna watch the guy that has like jim
ryan on his screen like with the
controller out like hey guys i get it
that's why the realm we we like all the
figures what was the third question the
third question that you could completely
pass was cool was just did you encounter
any bugs or anything you you played yeah
and here's the thing too this game has
bugs
it does i've experienced them i had a
sound bug
the the thing that is more apparent to
me which is kind of
i would say uh like surprise as a person
that you think playstation would you
know they're more of like these are the
uh less bugs like this is com a complete
package is
poppin and texture poppin
that's there
i've seen it it's happened to me uh
uh an amount of times for me to make
note of it like buildings uh don't pop
in as much i think the first the opening
cinematic i was like oh okay it's one of
the mechs their textures are like
literally popping in
here or there so yeah i've experienced
some but again it's not taking away from
my overall enjoyment of a thing no doubt
let's open it up uh lord area now has
been very patient he's got a lot to say
about pricing i feel he's got a lot to
say about metacritic so let's get it
okay tell me what your thoughts are not
that much so uh
joseph chose violence yeah you don't
hate me
oh boy here we go
let's get it that's why we got different
opinions on the panel
i'm not on the side of corporations at
all everybody who has seen me rant about
stuff knows that but i am fully on the
side of sony
break it down pricing let's hear it
first um
uh
as they don't owe you anything like they
set a price you either buy the game or
you don't they don't need they they
don't owe you marketing of the lowest
possible price they don't need to say
hey gamestop has it lower than we have
it or anything like that now like if
they said it's going to be available at
lower price they need to make it
available and they need to fix their
wording yeah and stuff like that i
completely agree with that
but as far as like like game prices
haven't went up a lot um in the past
however long so like if they want to say
hey this game as much as y'all just
talked about how big it is how pretty it
is how much they spent on this game
if they want to charge seventy dollars
for it hey that's a full right if you
don't want to pay seventy dollars for a
game so yeah i'm punching any games in
your backlog that you never even touched
ariel knight go play somebody buy that
could do right right um but but no like
uh i i i stand by sony just like i stand
by an indie dev or anybody else who
wants to price their game at a certain
rate i'll show that um
like you know you just kind of gotta
gotta
say you know this is the price right um
and gamers you know i'm not trying to
piss nobody off but you know there's a
little bit of privilege
a little bit of you know
a little bit that could be humorous
privilege
is that
that's like yeah entitlement that's in
there
that we kind of gotta like take note of
uh now really quickly on the review
thing yes i don't even think review
numbers should be a thing just because
there's a lot of people who don't like a
certain genre who has to review that
genre it is always going to be skewed so
i think the game industry in general
just be a better place if we just got
rid of the number and people like maybe
we made reviews shorter where you know
you can just kind of read it and just
understand their points because a lot of
people like my game but gave it a lower
score because there's some things that
just they they don't like about runners
right which is totally valid
i like you know all the low scores and
all the high scores me equally the same
as to me so we kind of just got to
understand the nuances between all of
these things and kind of like i know
everybody got their personal view on it
because how it affects them but you got
to see how it affects everybody the
round table is spicy today and i love it
i got three are you suggesting are you
suggesting that people then have to
actually read the article
god forbid that yo got messy
we gotta get some some opening opinions
because kiss move impatient and i know
where he's staying on certain things
this could be a spicy topic so just move
um about this uh horizon forbidden stuff
like let's see we're making up for
kingston we're making up for king today
all type of messi this but this is great
this is a good discussion a lot of
people on different side of the fence so
let's start with the first one you know
as far as you know the whole whole what
hog is bringing to light as far as the
version the visibility of the ps4 and
the ps5 version do you feel acid
deceptive practice and all that stuff
and then the second thing is the better
critic stuff because obviously the
streets as well and it is a strong
contingent that feel like yo you know
this should have been a 90 it is that
great how dare reviewer x say this this
that and this he has an agenda
and it needs to be 90. so currently 88
where where you at with both of these
things all right the first topic with
the whole pricing structure i ain't
gonna lie bro like i
i've been you guys heard me say i ain't
buying no game for seventy dollars
paid me i only bought returner for 70
because somebody had to pay me to play
the game
so
um and when it came to horizon i was
like all right
because
as a i i don't trust playstation so when
it came to buy i was like all right
the worst possible thing that can happen
is i go looking for the playstation 4
version of the game buying it and it
legit being the playstation 4.
not the ps5 and i was like i don't want
to do that like you know me so i was
like you know what not because i don't
have the disc version otherwise i would
have just went to the store
but the ps4 did something like all right
they promised me like so and they would
have done it that way i didn't know how
it would impact it digitally so i was
like you know what whatever
i got some gift cards
mind you i loaded these gift cards these
visa gift cards on my playstation 5 hit
the buy button and it snatched the money
out of my paypal which would connect to
my big account it completely ignored
it went straight to the straight to the
stash it didn't go it didn't go to the
okay i got you
so i bought it i was like whatever you
know i know i'm gonna like it it's right
or whatever so but the thing about it
though is that
they're
the the pricing situation i get what um
ariel was saying is like because they
don't have to they don't if i have if
i'm if i feel like i'm forced
to
reduce the price of my game because
y'all forgot i said lunch window game
yeah i forgot
then i was like okay i'll do that but i
ain't showing up with anywhere
you have to search the backlog for it
yep
i understand i understand that concept
it's like all right it's not free
it's like whatever you know what i mean
i completely understand them because i
figured i was like there's no way
they're going to advertise save ten
dollars by buying the place that you
poor version they're not going to do
that so
i'm not you understand the hustle you're
not bad at the house you understand
i'm not mad at them but i am but i've
always i'm not a fan of the games being
70 or this next gen tax and the only
reason why i'm against it because
there's too many publishers who haven't
opted to raise their game so i'm like
okay then what makes your game worth the
extra 10 bucks and if you're telling me
it's 10
because you get the extra enhancement
then i bought the ps5 because it's
supposed to do that to my games right if
the shouldn't dual set support
higher resolutions high frame rate be a
part of the price you pay for the places
you find so i'll ask you smooth just
like ask
king uh does it feel like playstation is
punishing you for early adopting on ps5
yeah this is this is what i said to
somebody right because somebody wanted
to argue with me right i was like okay
imagine this oh someone argue a kid
really
i was like imagine this imagine buying
you uh
imagine playing paying
a tax or a fee for a gaming or steam uh
library that you want to see with ray
tracing because you finally got an rtx
card um
[Laughter]
you know a thousand dollar tax to get
that rate trade
but that's the thing we get into
semantics
i paid 500 for the playstation 5.
right so pay 500 for the pc5 so that
means right even if i bought like less
even though they corrected themselves
but any game on ps4 that has features
that take that the ps5 can make the game
better
i shouldn't have to pay attacks for it
to
i have to agree with features
why do i have to pay extra to utilize
the ps5 feature all right let me give
you let me play devil advocate what
about because i know the the competition
is out there utilizing things like smart
delivery and and doing that but but what
about to ariel knight's point what what
if again in in the in the spirit of
business
they feel
that our product is worth this like like
for example like i'm i'm an android guy
right like i'm android all day right but
sometimes apple be like no no this is a
premium
ipod product or you know what i'm saying
and our price is here
and it's up to you to tell them they're
full of [ __ ]
so at the end of the day like what do
you say to that dude do you not buy into
that kid where it's like nah fam i'm
still i don't care okay you think it's
different okay break it down
it's because he had because he has an
apple i've got it yeah yeah yeah
i've got apple
yeah so they offer two different ps two
is that different price point one's
missing the disk drive right
is horizon zero is verizon forbidden
west
one a game or two different games on uh
places before in places oh is it one
game or is it two different games
it's two different games i know what
he's doing i know what he's doing
getting
gays move
um so
the playstation all right so horizon
forbidden west is technically it's it's
one game is it verizon forbidden west on
ps4 it's right for forbidden west for
horizon forbidden west on ps5 it's
verizon forbidden west if you want to do
some shenanigans like that
will a nintendo call it horizon
forbidden west red
if you want if you want to do that and
you know it's funny smooth it was it was
proven that those pokemon games are the
same game but when you when you load up
the switch the switch determines which
game you have and they unlock which side
of the disc of the cartridge that you
use
well you know in my like i think there
is points to what kid smooth's saying
which is like yeah no like should they
really be charging you an extra 10 bucks
no they are and that's up to the market
to decide is is that something they're
willing to to stick up with you know you
say whatever you want but if the
market's like if we wake up on monday
and the thing is sold 4.7 million you
know copies the market people didn't
care well yeah so that's why i said
my issues with it is because not
everyone has adopted it and that's what
creates that problem if everybody it'd
be different if like the standard like
what they did during the 360 ps3 era
where everything just went boom 60 bucks
it is what it is i ain't i'm not gonna
stop but you're gonna tell me these
couples
publishers is doing 70 but everybody
else is still doing 60 then like but i
understand that and my last one before
opened up but what what if they got the
numbers and the analytics and say yo
that's 70 ain't hurting our base they go
out and support they buy this they you
know i'm saying why should we have to
lower them
we're the premium tier
i'm just i'm i'm just talking i'm being
corporate cars for a second that's the
same corporation i have to produce well
another million ps4 is just
oh my god
because people waited
they did a midnight release on
metacritic scores because somebody
wanted to be the first to put this game
against forza horizon or halo
how much better it was
they couldn't do that so that set ablaze
the fact that they couldn't say it was
this much better
than the xbox game it it it just that
blaze mind you if there was if
the fact think about it if forza horizon
5 was an uh 88 87 halo 5 was a 84-83 if
psychonuts wasn't as great then they
would have been fine
but the problem is
these xbox games hit a tear
of many credit scores that was like he's
not wrong like
if if xbox games last year would have
flopped entirely i don't think we would
be
so you implying that the main source of
this vitriol
was payback i will
when i went from an 89 to 88 was smooth
a little happy just be honest oh lord
he's part of the problem part of the
problem
because i knew i would see less memes
but the thing was here's an issue though
this is but this is what happens with
the playstation fanboys right
and the journalists back then
they spent so much time overrating
everything playstation did that they
scored zero dawn too high
okay now
this is going left already for when
forbidden west came out
which is probably an accurate score uh
the law's average is probably an
accurate score and pretty fine that when
i look at that score i was like 89.89
this is coming from the individual that
has a whole series on youtube called
surviving metacritic scores so
anyway moving on moving on because this
kid is in his bag right now addict
what's up man um how do you feel about
this whole what do you want me to do two
things two things the uh either one the
the the metacritic and the whole
controversy with the playstation 4
version 50 you know i mean 60 and the
what you call being seven you'll pay for
like there was three things people were
doing wasn't there yeah and then the box
but julian plays right there oh well
i'll uh
i the only thing i want to say about the
bugs is i find it ironic
that this same type of bugs that was in
dying light too
is in horizon and no one's really
bringing up these i don't know about
that sir
but no okay but
look all i'm saying
is horizon has some crazy bugs and when
you read these reviews
it doesn't reflect the buzz but when you
read the dying light reviews that's all
they talked about and then all i'm
saying is someone who is poo who got the
dying light review code that game i did
too
yo that game rough
rough in certain parts that told me he
still can't we still can't play the
multiplayer together like we still can't
even play it because people are
disconnecting and like he told me you
don't even start it clock just wait i'll
let you know when it's safe to come back
here and i gotta let you know what it's
saying that's what they told me like i
was like and i trust this is the luck
all i'm saying is see we're not really
debating on dying like two getting right
getting hit like it did we're debating
on
i honestly truly feel like somebody like
there's some influences that i saw like
i felt like what their response was to
it uh when it come to the the bugs made
sense to what they said right but some
of these people would talk literally for
three or four paragraphs or a couple
minutes about bugs and they give it a
nine out of ten
like but i don't feel like dying like
two got that opportunity like they were
like oh you know we're going we're gonna
say this we will give it a five out of
ten five out of ten this is a weird take
i got to say it
he been going hard for this i i i
disagree with you but look he been he
been riding on it
when it comes to this certain developers
and certain publishers get passes on
stuff and i've honestly and truly if
this would have been like an xbox game
and they had this many bugs it would it
would be a wrap i'm sorry it would get a
massive six sevens out of tens but
horizons getting mad nines and tens out
of things i'm not really going too much
into the metacritic score
if i can't go
all i'm saying when it comes to this is
i just personally feel like that when it
comes to that type of perspective i
don't think that i it's like when it
comes to certain developers that certain
publishers and certain things can live
without i feel like they're willing to
go straight in
techland oh okay it's techland you know
we can we can we can really put a dot on
our stuff when it comes to something
like sony which have i have i uh which
we all know have been very
what's what i'm looking for particularly
how they do their review process it was
like oh yeah we we had this look box
little bugs we got some bugs nine out of
ten but when it comes to dying light
though solution positivity the entire
review and the last couple of minutes
they'll say okay we had this bug this
bug five out of ten like i'm sorry i
just i personally feel like when it
comes to stuff like that i don't like
that you know
and i said it last week and this week
it's happening with with horizon
okay i feel like halo infinite got nines
and eight point fives and it didn't have
a slayer mode
when it launched
there is difference between those stuff
not being there day one and games not
launching that's not functioning
there's a difference between playing it
and not yes that is true there's
definitely a difference between playing
it in that let's get forte he's been
patient and then we're gonna move on
cause this is coming we got forte yeah
yeah whatever bro
he he wanted he threw the bat he said
cog tagged me in on this please listen
what's up i literally i literally had to
walk away and go on break
this is crazy talk to me
so
oh my god all right so let let's first
let's just let's talk about the pricing
the pricing you know i wasn't i was you
know shout out to dps i want to point
out
shut up
we had a place that we had our
playstation rep on and this man had the
nerve to tell me that it was retails um
it was their uh responsibility i got you
how they could save money but whatever
but let's let's let's just talk about
this price thing now ultimately
they don't have to do anything but i
just feel like it's the fact of the
matter that they knew that there was a
firestorm around this one particular
game when it came to price and the fact
that they said that you were gonna be
able to do a and then they tried to spin
move people and say you can't do this
right so
the fact of the matter is just one thing
they they
they should have just stuck by and just
said you know what we're just going to
eat this we're not going to try to you
know lollygag and hide stuff from people
because they knew everybody was going to
be paying super aware
to this one game in particular because i
do believe that this is business as
usual
like it's their responsibility to put on
the front page that you can get this for
cheaper if you get on the ps4 i i 100
agree with that fact but it's just with
this game in particular
they missed the mark they knew that it
was going to be a firestorm around this
and that's why they started changing
terms and services and stuff you know
when does the company go through and
change their faq
the day after a huge news item like this
breaks literally less than 24 hours
later they knew they were in the wrong
for that because they were trying to
like spin this in a different narrative
but that's just the simple fact i think
sony just messed up on that regard and
they just feel like they should have
just left them alone okay now this
metacritic thing
oh okay i got you after kick because i
know i mean after all four tickets and i
forgot something yeah this this this
metacritic thing is the most dumbest
thing i've ever heard in my life because
this is nothing new everybody knows that
you're gonna have people that are gonna
give crappy reviews to a game no matter
what and everybody knows you're going to
get reviews that absolutely make no
sense that are 100
like playstation lifestyle like when is
the last time playstation lifestyle gave
a playstation game less than a 90.
are we going to sit here and make it
seem like they're they're non-biased to
the situation are we going to sit here
at like i mean this ain't just a
playstation thing this is an xbox thing
with xbox universe we're going to act
like xbox universe is going to give an
xbox game less than a 90. every time i
look up those so it's literally an
average of everything people want to
just look at the scenario and say oh
look at this 65. let's be for real y'all
using this for list wars
that's all this is about the fact that
horizon forbidden west did not get a 90
metacritic it's hurting people's
feelings out there
that's all this conversation is if the
game was at a 92 or a 93 guess what
nobody would have said anything guess
what nobody said anything about god of
war because where the god of war
finished at and everything nobody was
like oh look at these crappy with now
review sites like stevie are giving god
award a 50. didn't nobody say nothing
because the review was where it needed
to be so the fact that it was one number
off people lost their freaking minds
and they forgot the core element that
this is nothing new
so
to me that's that's all i got to say
about it just listening to you guys
trying to get a quick question around
yeah so um like it's more of a general
question too
two detroit natives in there going at it
right now shout out i'm not even going
i'm i'm just i'm i'm instigating
uh prices drop so quickly why why
why not just wait like if if you want
horizon at 60 or below just just wait
two months like i don't understand that
part
no i'm not even attacking nobody i'm
this is just your question no no i i
agree with that but and if you are the
type of person that's willing to wait
for games like a lot of people in the
community said i don't wait for games i
don't wait for this if i want to play it
i'm gonna play it day one i agree if you
if if you're about the price wait
because games do drop in price within
the first couple of months of them being
out but i just look at it for nintendo
guys
but like i said i just look at just once
yeah i just looked at this one situation
where
they told people what was going to
happen and they should have just
completely made it transparent from
beginning to end because they knew why
that if they changed it
people would notice it if it would if
they would have never said anything
about um next-gen upgrades in july of
last year nobody would have even cared
about the ps4 aerial night asking why
forte why they have to yeah why that's
his question
they don't even have to say anything no
but he's saying why they why they have
to be transparent as far as the pricing
that's your specific question no no they
just had to be no just no in games in
general they don't have to but for this
game they do because they told people
one thing back in july
and then they tried to tell you
something else
earlier wait now they think in july that
you're referencing is when they said
cross generation won't have to pay for
an upgrade
yeah exactly once they said that that
was the that was the that was the key
point right there then they tried to
tell people like oh no you we're not
giving free upgrades for the standard
edition and legendary in the living in
the launch edition of horizon forbidden
west once they said that then everybody
was like yo wait a minute hold up you
told everybody that this game was going
to be a cross-platform game that you buy
it once you get it on both systems that
was where they made their mistake if
they would have just never said anything
about cross-platform you know play you
got to remember this is when xbox was
going really really hard with saying
smart delivery we're going to be able to
use you know whatever game you have is
going to recognize the system you have
and it's going to give you that upgrade
automatically so sony was in that moment
was like we need to do something to let
people know if they get a ps5 that these
games are going to be a cross-platform
thing and you just buy it once you get
it on both and guess what they tried to
change that on people a year later and
that was the issue so if they would have
never tried to just follow what's up
what microsoft was doing to stick to
their guns in general nobody would even
care about this conversation but it's
just the fact that they try to do it
with this one game and that's the
problem
fair enough addict didn't get the chance
to finish his bars though i gotta let
addicts finish this ball then solve and
then we move on
uh so what's so
you talked about the um the metacritic
but i don't think we got you the thing
on the on the pricing right and and we
talked about the bugs you talk about the
bugs i'm sorry
i mean when it comes to the pricing
look i think it's sleazy
i do especially offering a deluxe
edition for both platfor for both
platforms when you know there's a free
upgrade i don't think that they
originally tended to do this i think the
backlash
is what changed that original because if
you look at it
they didn't they weren't originally
going to do with a couple games and they
ended up like going back on it uh i
don't think that was the plan here i
feel like you guys know how i've always
felt i i do feel like sony doesn't
appreciate the the day one purchases of
the ps5 uh you know i just
in no realm shape or form am i going to
feel like
charging people to use features that you
promoted with the console was right
if they could do what they want they're
the owners of it and it's like you know
when it comes to the the 10 difference
thing like
i don't care because i ain't buying the
game right but like
if you guys feel strong about this go
talk to you
a lawyer and follow a class action
lawsuit
that's the only thing you could really
do like what are you gonna do like
you're not gonna buy the game you won't
go and buy the game anyway um like it's
just like look like as far as like
waiting for cells like we impatient
people we ain't doing that like
it's just like look like
they got us by our hobby and i've always
said
you punish companies that take advantage
of your hobby
but at the end of the day if they want
to do that they want to charge 90 and
you guys go out and spend 90. i'm sony
i'm like yo let's charge 100.
it's just like look like
if you feel that strong don't buy the
game that's the fact i i i don't know
what else to say when it comes to stuff
like i feel like it is sleazy i'm not
going to ever like go against the
consumer base on something that i truly
do feel is a wrong move and them
charging an extra 10
and as far as like hiding the
playstation like i'm not on my ps5 a lot
but when i am they don't really promote
ps4 editions of anything right
no so i'm sorry i don't think that they
would like people's like oh they're
hiding the playstation 4 edition horizon
i didn't see the playstation 4 edition
of uh sifu
i didn't see the playstation 4 edition
of of any of the games i do like they
don't really put but they don't put them
on the front page and stuff yeah i see
it when i do digital but attic yeah but
attic that's what i'm talking about it
would those all those other games you
were just talking about there's no issue
because there was no controversy around
any of those games when it came to
pricing
is this game in particular because of
what they did a year and a half ago so
that's the only reason this is in the
news that's it
just to clarify
when
you buy a game they because i i didn't
even try to buy this like do they is the
ps4 edition not even on the store did
they take it off the store that's the
horizon
for verizon i personally did not see the
playstation 4 version but but my thing
is when i go and buy games on the
playstation 5
unless i directly search for the ps4
version like search the game word for
word and they all pop in
if you go into the playstation store and
sort it by ps4 it will show you every
game in there that's ps4 right horizon
zero dawn i mean
here's the point i know where you're
going at it and i got to jump in this is
the problem i have the problem i have my
ps4
yeah you do
but the problem i have is that i go say
okay i'm gonna search miles morales or
whatever it is
in my opinion if i'm on the ps5 right
i don't know why i'm seeing all these
versions of of a different console to be
honest what i'm saying like it just
seems a little weird anyway so if if if
that was already the status quo that
when i search for a game they're going
to show me the ps4 version and they're
going to show me the ps5 version right
which they've kind of shown me every
time i do digital because i'm pretty
much all digital but in this case
it's like nah fam his fierce five
version yeah and i know there's a ps4
version because we know about the ten
dollar thing so that's what i think
where forte is saying where they're
getting a lot of the vitriol because in
every other case they've made both
available which i personally don't even
like i don't i feel if i have a ps5
honestly i shouldn't even see a bf i do
agree with that but it's like they've
already set the precedent that they've
done it all these other times so it is
weird guys so i think the president was
set because they messed up like right i
think they they really had
that whole thing with the dual skus on
the ps5 was never supposed to be a thing
i don't know it was it was
we talked about how the ui was kind of
coming in hot and the things they did
with the ui to sort of make it be
different kind of it just it just took a
a ui that was simple and worked well and
confused it for no reason so i think
that underlying layer whether you're
seeing the ps4 version for no reason on
your ps5 it's just something that they
for whatever reason right haven't been
able to get away from them
to jump in and again that's why because
to be honest i'm not trying to counsel
all this thing i thought xbox was just
marketing talk with smart dude i'm like
yeah whatever fam that you smart
delivery whatever right but now when i
see i'm like oh okay and now i don't
have to pay a ten dollars or whatever it
is to upgrade it or have the enhancement
that's going to take advantage of my new
console it's automatically intrinsically
going to be upgraded so here comes attic
screen sharing and that's what it is so
yeah what's that what you doing
i'm going you going i'm just
we we're going to do homework for a
second can you see it right yeah because
clearly you didn't do this before to
show what you should have but no like i
i didn't know but the way people are
acting like it like yeah it's a thing
you look at this you click the horizon
game it's it's the ps5 version
and ps4 but
but you guys say it's hidden like it
literally says it right there let's see
if you scroll down
and it's like the different version
right ps5
i just okay so yeah there's no ps4 over
there but i i i've never seen that like
let's let's look this is another process
go go go to miles go to um what you call
it
go to a miles on morales that's another
one
because i ain't honest enough to to know
what's going on see the ps5 ps4 version
so if you go down
maybe scroll are you going too fast
okay choose which edition you got the
ultimate
this is the ps5 version but you have you
got it you have to click on the the
three little dots and that will show you
it'll you'll change the version there
ultimate edition the ps5 version
like i i've never seen them just openly
try to get me to buy a ps4 version of
anything
well what's another game you do have to
i'm i'm with attic on this one you do
have to do a little extra
leg work to see the ps4 version yeah for
sure
to me like if you look up the actual
game horizon
then you see
oh it comes up both
yeah there it is right and you see
there's no there is
i didn't see what y'all feel if this
wasn't a sony studio
i don't know well see we don't have that
option we don't have that issue because
microsoft has this part done like for
the most part
i'm talking about the studio that makes
the game gorilla you're talking about
the platform awards i don't think
anybody
anybody can
we can't really go on something like
that because it's a store like it's not
like like you can't go because i got a
website
you know
you know what's funny yeah this is the
last we'll ever hear about this because
you're paying 70 moving forward
jim made that very clear so gran turismo
70 dollars
no doubt look we got him we dragging
this crazy um one last question
and we haven't asked this yet so much of
the first game
was
was talked about through the lens of
breath of the wild right a lot of it
sometimes says detriment sometimes not
in a week we get eldon ring
and elden ring
has been rumored to do things with open
world that we haven't seen before that
it is really taking that you know that
adventure the idea of of an open world
adventure game and taking it to that
next level
with that with that from sauce that
makes it you know difficult whatever do
you think we start talking about
forbidden west through a lens of
what
el elden ring
does to kind of push the genre forward
did we start talking about that in a
week so like you think like the the the
zeitgeist the same effect the same right
the same effect that kind of birth of
the wild had it'll happen again with
elven rings
oh i see what you say like his history
could repeat itself because right oh
look i'll jump in because i didn't get
too much talk everyone's talking oh yeah
thank you i like to get my opinion
sometimes um you know i i think this
i i am concerned only because of the
timing we all came into february like
good lord we got to make business
decisions you know what i'm saying
because if you got if you're adele if
you're a souls guy this is what you've
been waiting for this is the dream joint
you know what i'm saying if you're a
sony guy you like yo horizon gorilla you
know at his peak like pushing boundaries
touching destiny what i'm saying then
i'm a destiny guy so i'm like i don't
care what none of y'all talking about
i'm on witch queen like i i don't really
care like that's just what it is for me
so sorry so it's like for again i don't
know the key is gonna be if
alvin ring lands the plane correct
if eldon ring lands the plane and it's
clear smooth and there's no glitches no
bugs no major issues and then aren't
they attempting some form of co-op in
there in their game as well
i mean they've there's always been
called right their games right and then
but also in conjunction with an open
world right so it's like they're really
broadening the scope they got a lot to
do i'm not saying they won't execute but
if they do then i would solve if elder
ring hits
it's it's going out of this world like
that's just how the souls community is
and i'm not a souls guy but i respect
them i know when that game hit i've seen
kids smooth do them games on stream i
seen what the attention it brings people
love to see the pain of others go
through the boss or whatever it's just a
thing it's it's a movement and i if it
hits then yes off i don't think horizon
can survive that if it's if it's that
but and i think to to the to the
metacritic point which i'll answer i
think that's why the fanboys are in an
uproar because a lot of them are putting
their stake like yo if we get
that 90 plus
we on the keegley show and we could
throw this in people's faces i think
they're going to be on that
show like that's let's call it what it
is that people and then to what you know
kid was saying i do agree on some level
that it's like yo like you know the xbox
community at the end of the last year
they had a great end of year forza
horizon i critically claimed horizon i
mean horizon
halo infinite acclaim right so people
want to throw this score over you like
yeah fam the real dogs are here this is
the real you know what i'm saying and p
some people can't do that you don't say
because and that's where we get the
thing but to the point about the ten
dollars i'm gonna stay on my square on
it i do think
it is deceptive marketing i i do i'm not
gonna sugarcoat it i do agree with neil
airlord ariel knight that they have
earned the right to charge whatever they
want that is correct they you value is
it perceived that's what you said is
your value you think it's worth i'm all
about you get your back however all i
say is like can you just be
clear where where where the pricing is
that's all i care about just because
most gamers let's be real are going to
want to know they don't want to go
through a website and they don't want to
go through some back-end app to try to
find a version to save money especially
to forte's point if they got on their
soapbox and said hey guys we're sorry
about the cross-generational thing we're
sorry we're gonna you know we're gonna
make this free upgrade for people for
those first generation joints so we're
not gonna pay and then they kind of do
this then it's kind of
the moral transparency is on you to make
that available in my opinion but attic
let's get each other comment and then we
gotta move on because
the only thing i like
i don't really care what they do with
the pricing thing but the only thing i'm
really
that makes me go towards your guys is
more i'm like 60 50 60 40. you know what
i'm saying is that deluxe edition that
promotes both of them that's the one
that i look at that i'm like
you can't realistically expect me to
believe that this was well thought of
when you have free upgrade you're
selling a deluxe edition for like 20
dollars more
that comes with both when they're free
upgrades so
yeah i'm with you i just don't like the
weight the handling of the upgrades i
said it would go sushi man that's my
favorite game i love them oh my god but
i didn't like the way to practice look
we're more low enough super chats we got
more we got two other topics
i didn't think this was going to go do
all this
jesus
would you be fair you did have three
topics in one topic so well what it was
was three aspects the the game has so
much to talk about in fairness
what you guys saw
yeah let me roll oh you're rolling back
rolling back no doubt oh [ __ ] mods i
need the mods in here we got people
trying to do things
mods get them get them out here trying
to sell a website
please
let's go
all right cool uh so we got heart gate
to me ten dollars with a chat the
playstation joke about monopoly is
because of this exclusive cod is a
monopoly number one revenue number one
revenue game is pokemon at 90 billion
mario's number two at three at 30
billion cod is three at 17 billion his
nintendo monopoly issue is game pass not
cod that is a very good point
then we got hot grits nine ten five
dollars
uh yo i'm xbox first but these sony
exclusives put the money on the screen
with graphics fidelity they almost never
missed they've always done it they've
always done it yeah
then we have donald taco five dollars of
a chat horizon forbidden west is a nice
appetizer for the real open world game
of the years breath of the wild 2 in
star field maybe horizon 3 it will
surpass birth of the wild one so that's
wow this guy you know donald tucker you
know
going to choke somebody through the
screen
yeah we got splendiferous remember for
five butts
so what are y'all telling me is that she
want a date but she don't want a date
she wanna talk to you but she don't
wanna talk to you she's gonna be very
she's gonna be a very hungry woman oh my
god
ridiculous ridiculous
there we have graham c five dollar super
chat horizon is the most effort i've
ever seen put into rendering dreads and
it's for a white girl
movie guys
there we go
five dollar super chat
remedy releasing its first thinker made
king sick that get well soon bro
then we got owen coggins the secret
nintendo fanboy oh my god
an account that's called it toast is
more interesting
that's crazy
yeah we got splendiferous once again
2000. yes
he he has buried his nes under the xbox
and his ps5
okay
then we got cw griswold five dollar
super chat horizon forbidden west is
fire but it has issues bad collision
detection no anti-aliasing 60 fps mode
and some bugs that cause uh frame rate
issues
not perfect that's fine
always cola five dollar super chat with
metacritic people need to realize that
is that the world does not move to the
beat of just one drum what might be
right for you might not be right for
something
good
is that yeah is that different strokes
yeah i think that's what different
struggles
yeah and we got freddy fox coming out
old gangsters
he used to shake up the south bronx back
in the day salute to him
what's up fellas loving horizon
forbidden west but i've got some really
bad popping at times hoping it gets
fixed because the pop-in wasn't that bad
in the first game
i gotta pay more attention because i
have not seen any of that
you know you know solve i never see that
kind of stuff like
i have always like
i never see it yeah
i mean i wasn't looking for it
necessarily but i guess i'll look for it
i know people that'll see one frame and
see it no but some people who really
like sky boxes and you want to look over
the horizon
right yeah yeah i can see yeah some
people that it depends on how you your
game play focuses
that we got the ever born saga five
dollar super
best lens to look at meta scores is with
a five point standard deviation yeah a
lot of people going to five point scales
now yeah
and we have matt tichbon remember for
two months thank you sir i've been an
xbox boy since day one but horizon
forbidden west really has me thirsting
for a playstation
all right i guess that's the desired
effect yeah yeah
clearly doesn't want his he always say
it won't you hit up with them
continue
there we got jay nichols five dollar
super chat
they the ps content fakers won't call
them out horizon forbidden west was
delayed a year and a single player only
game with bugs if it was halo it would
get a 6.5
okay
there's a lot to say it's like why
people care so much about this squad
over move it all i don't want to drag
this good to you
and we got hot grits once again two
dollars in the chat yo i need them
review numbers fam yeah i see a lot of
people just if the number is easy i i
get it it's easy to digest but
kind of doing the review of the service
um
har gee cheney five dollar super chat
horizon uplift and cost could be
considered fraudulent waiting for the
lawsuit
you sound like you eager
oh yeah what's up he ready
good
majestic ten dollars how does sony get
away with seventy dollars price point
with a seven dollar price point they
would kill xbox yes xbox
xbox
listen they're not they're gonna be as
consumer friendly as possible we know
this
then we got black ronin member for 10
months i agree with addict uh uh dl2 is
fun and the minor bugs i came across
aren't as bad as the stuff i've seen him
and for uh and
he has the the numbers wrong horizon
forbidden west he has the letters wrong
so i'm like what the hell game is that
forbidden horizon west um eloise skating
around like the winter olympics i didn't
see any of that man
it was funny right
there's a bug running around oh okay
yeah well yeah
i've seen a couple people posting that
their consoles was breaking over the
platform yes and yeah wow let's get it
knock on wood um big cloud game remember
for 12 months shout out to you brother
hello
i'm late as usual what up lord's panel
in chat horizon is addicting no doubt
enjoy my brother absolutely
love the mutual respect being shown by
everyone in the panel i'll be showing
everyone how it's done hit the like
button folks show your support exactly
every every every opinion here is
welcome as long as it said respect
exactly we can all differ but we need to
be respectful that's all we ask
then we got duve five dollar super chat
the real issue is the pricing if it's a
free upgrade why not have both at sixty
dollars at sixty dollars it wouldn't
matter what version of it is showing
shady station five
yo
moving on
oh let me see if we had any more that
jumped me
we got mr come on
yeah
yeah three pound super chat seventy
percent ps5 30 ps4 uk physical for all
for a white case okay physically
yeah physical gaming dragon heart yobe
five dollar super chat listen iron lords
presents this is the future talk and iop
video game um
just wait on an iop burst the seeds have
been planted hashtag peace of life
absolutely love
and we have mr irishman member for eight
months ps5 games here in north northern
ireland are 70 pounds which is much
closer to 95 dollars
it's a real thing for some issue vote
with your wallet man well however you
want to do it but uh let's move on
attic you're up man um what's going on a
lot of ea have a town hall
some are saying you know as far as uh
battlefield the reasons why they may
have received not received a success but
then he kind of made a statement about
you know saying that not entirely all of
it's true but what's your thoughts this
is your topic we'll let you kick it off
apparently
they are
oh we we all know what happened with
battlefield you know they uh they came
out that game
it was it had a lot of network issues a
lot of bugs in general they made overall
decisions about the game that you know a
lot of the core community didn't like
and then i instead of
taking
all of that at face value and looking
from the inner to to figure out what
they did wrong
they came out and blamed halo
infinites up oh man i'm sorry carl can
you feel it i got you i got you i got
you yeah now you got you bro so look you
know this has been the controversy an
issue um report was that they were
allegedly you know blaming covet halo
infinite amongst other factors but you
know the vibe they actually gave more
clarification in in this town home
meeting as far as the vibe and they
admit it like they failed to meet player
expectation they pretty much said um
that they were utilizing an older engine
and as far as from frostbite and then
they moved to a new engine which they
said you know it gave the development
team more variables than before
um yeah they did talk about obviously
the surprise launch of uh hill infinite
at that time
but they really felt like um the
critical reception just wasn't wasn't as
good and then they they elaborated to to
say that they're going to really look
into it so you know what's what's the
vibe let's start with what's up whatever
tonight um you know what what's your
vibe when you see you know ea kind of
like get in front of this and list the
reasons to why they felt you know they
didn't meet player expectation
um
i don't know uh when i first heard it i
didn't really care i was like this is
like a quote without context right i'm
sure they like you know
you got to think about the people who
made the game um who sorry from talking
too low again the people who made the
game who have to like uh sit there and
you know their jobs on the line they got
to figure out you know what they can do
better what uh they couldn't control
what they could control um i don't think
it's uh a necessarily wrong take to say
a surprise halo
kind of messed up day numbers right
because you know any game that came out
that same day would have got you know
would have got flexed on by halo it was
hell uh yeah so i can't you know it is
what it is i ain't mad at it yeah no i
feel that i feel that it is what it is
let's get up let's get
get kicked because um i feel like he's
really got a lot of
battlefield call of duty type of
sensibility sometimes but um where you
at with this when ea comes out and makes
these statements and you know alleged
town meeting as far as again we don't
have the direct quotes for everything
but that was what alleged what was just
some of the factors
yeah i'm not surprised i'm just happy
they acknowledged it i said this would
happen um
that halo is going to have an impact on
battlefield and call of duty maybe more
battlefield than it does call of duty
because call of duty was still going to
sell but we've seen battlefield you know
struggle before in terms of
not hitting uh the metrics that they're
targeting you know they you know they
stumbled out of the gate with um after
they did one which was like all right
you know they stumbled out of the gate
with five because people had their you
know they had a bad pr problem with that
and then this was supposed to be the the
savior uh but the thing is the writing
was on a wall from
the the buggy beta the delays yeah um
it was pretty rough yeah yeah and i'm
pretty sure they they saw they knew like
come on industry talks i mean
the game came out a week after halo
infinite
so
they delayed it right did they delay it
like two weeks or something initially
yeah and yeah the game was originally
supposed to come out in october and i
think the game ended up coming out in
the last week of november
the thing is though
it does at the end you still we're going
to eat your your pre-orders is your
pre-orders i'm pretty sure your
pre-orders would solidify you know well
beyond you know the the release date um
because from to my understanding didn't
battlefield start out strong on player
base
i don't remember over top i just know
there was a tremendous drop-off yeah it
was a tremendous drop-off at that point
halo's already been out and you know
computer been saying halo's no dead
they keep highlighting halo's uh steam
numbers dropping off at that point
though you would think
um i feel like
sure you can blame covert every
publisher and developers blaming kobe
has impacted everyone so i'm not they
can get that
halo yeah it had
an impact on them but i think at the end
of the day you remove halo
from this instance i think
battlefield still suffers the same fate
uh because at the end of the day it's
not like they address any of the issues
that the game has or anything like that
didn't they just delay their season as
well so
it doesn't have a scoreboard
yeah
yeah that that that too
bad i mean if kids were finished then oh
baby you could jump right on it if you
have kids
yeah but no no that's uh i just was
happy that they um
acknowledged it that that halo you know
had some input because i've been saying
it's going to impact one of those games
but
i'm a skedaddle like i feel like i'm
running on like uh uh
fumes right now about appreciation
brother thank you for
coming through bro for real i appreciate
it shout out to ariel bad [ __ ]
sovereign addict cognito and
appreciation lord sorry no doubt brother
one bro have a good one bro no doubt hey
yo uh uh real quick yeah i just want to
know um that people saying you know
battlefield's blaming halo i don't think
it has anything to do with blaming right
i think it's uh just pointing out
pointing out the situations yeah people
people forget that um my game came out
uh last week same day as the cyberpunk
update yeah
what you're going to do
yeah like what you're going to do
exactly and shout out to shout out that
no it's a good point everyone shout to
que asante made a good point in
conjunction with what you said he said
well to be fair they didn't necessarily
blame hillary they basically said they
didn't release a good product and then
halo came out more polished she said
it's the media that spun it to make it
sound like they blamed hill that's
actually a good point they didn't
actually say yo halo and video if you
wouldn't you don't say but i understand
i understand anything but continue let's
get this going um i got to get mr
babbitt forte if he's still here but get
out there all right bro let's get up
let's get that bit though i want it
because bad [ __ ] even chime in real
quick on this oh i'm sorry this hurts
i'm a huge battlefield fan have been
since
god i think like battlefield 2. it's
been a minute so
um you know that trailer got me
originally where you got that guy
popping out of the chat with the rock
watcher
[Music]
after hearing the buggy alpha and then
the excuses out of people in the beta i
kind of knew where things were gonna go
with that game unfortunately and you
know from what we understand it did not
hit any of its sales goals
um so this is
this is catastrophic for a brand in a
series that i really love and appreciate
um
it's it's just sad yeah this isn't them
blaming halo this is just it's just one
of the many things that
really were evident at that launch that
that hurt it and
the only people that they have to blame
are themselves because they wanted to
appeal
to shareholders at the end of the day uh
they wanted to make sure that those
numbers were
on the up and up and
i i feel as a battlefield fan it did uh
irreparable and just made up a word i
love it to that
to that to that series i don't know how
it comes back how do you get the faith
because battlefield usually launches a
little rough around the edges but you
don't have a scoreboard yeah you don't
have any way to to you don't even have
voice chat
bro i know it was cool what is this when
they brought vince impeller in
yeah i'm like
so it just it just hurts because i i you
know i don't want to see anybody
her over there at dice they're already
working their their their butts off so
it's just
it sucks to see that said though i do
also have to head out now
no no no no brother brother you guys
held it down man we needed to go we put
the call out and
the realm came through to hold us down
we appreciate it
we had a two hour horizon uh yeah
conversation that just was organic you
know but i'll tell people where they can
find you what you got going on before
you have bro of course man you can find
me over at mr bad bit you can find my
podcast the trophy room a playstation
podcast made by the players for the
players for each and every thursday me
and my best friend kyle talk about the
latest agreements on all things
playstation
each and every thursday uh find us on
apple podcast google play
uh all those places maybe check out a
review that will be hitting
the podcast
let's go
a pleasure meeting you ariel uh
and kid who's gone now but also lord
cognito my brother man you've been
killed thank you brother my brother and
solving attic you guys are just all
right i love you hey you guys are just
uh
thank you
much
love you guys peace brother forte you're
still rocking i just want to make sure
yo what's up
because
this was the one me and you say yo we
playing this day one we don't get one
i was like halo gonna be in the bushes
with battlefield
oh listen man this one hurts because
like i agree with everybody i don't
think in general that they were like
blaming halo for it it was just the kind
of the situation but
they knew what they were doing they you
first of all when it's when everything
is falling around falling apart around
you you don't
turn around and blame someone else you
look at yourself and say
what did we do to our major franchise
that everybody's having a problem with
it
and
it was just a situation where i just
feel like
once the hit detection was busted in the
game there's no scoreboard in the game
it's like look i put over a thousand
hours in battlefield 4. and that was
like one of the most busted games you
can play yeah when it came out and it
took them two years to fix that game but
it was something about that game when it
came to just the gameplay style where
the game worked it was amazing and it
worked 90 of the time it was just battle
of 10 percent of the time but this game
there's just no redeeming qualities for
it it's like everything is it's like
it's like we talk about halo being a
skeleton of itself i mean battlefield's
not even it's not even an entity at this
point like what is this game and then
it's just
it's just disheartening to hear them
talk about
this game and i come to the realization
that you know ea is definitely at fault
but i'm starting to believe that dice
isn't what i thought they were
you know dice spicy look you can only
you can only rock with a studio for so
long and i gave and i gave three four
three this same smoke
i was like you did they haven't given us
a complete halo game over the course of
the last generation this is the best
that we have gotten and correct the game
is still being polished and finished up
and the jury's still out on that but for
dice over the last generation every
battlefield game they've given us has
been problem after problem fix after fix
even going back to the star wars games
which people real they made the star
wars the battlefront won the battlefront
2 they created those games too
and this is a consistent thing with them
so as much as we blame ea because of
micro transactions and getting games out
in front of quarters we also got to
blame the fact that yo dice their you
know what's really going on when it
comes to just the development of these
games and getting them out i understand
you're under a deadline right but yeah
sometimes you just gotta tell the
develop the publisher like yo this game
isn't gonna be it's not gonna be right
it's not gonna be ready we can't get
this out because you're basically going
to kill this franchise and if that's the
case then bye-bye battlefield but it
hurts my soul because outside of destiny
this is my second favorite franchise
when it comes to first-person shooters
and i just i can't i can't even attempt
to defend this game because there's
nothing to defend yeah no that's real
that's real brother appreciate it sorry
i gotta head out you guys um like you
guys are amazing shout out to you
which i knew what happened but you know
some people in the chat was like i don't
know it's gonna be
a lot of subs
but yeah right exactly so you guys have
a great day neil
well forte before you go don't also tell
people where they can find you and
what's going on oh yeah well you can you
can find me at fort gaming forte youtube
twitter that's my side playstation where
my mic is 75 better than it is right now
at work
but um yeah it's a it's good to be here
dps podcast with my homeboy slumbo
backslash every thursday 9 p.m um it
will be on his channel next week it's on
my channel this week so
you guys have a great weekend i gotta
read this super chat he said slow mo two
dollar super chat once again frostbite
engine is trash you know how he'd be
going hard on frostbite
no slander on rest in peace dizzy no
slander no slander when uh frostbite is
mitchell because dizzy can dizzy would
go hard for foreign
but definitely you guys have a great
rest of the show and um
neil nice to meet you bro like i said
even though you're a lioness fan i still
respect you uh matthew stafford shout
out to matthew stafford for proving
those lines wrong
battlefield what you feeling on this uh
ea's assessments
um it's funny someone took like one of
my bait one of my points right there
so slander
it's the first thing obviously the the
you know
look at mainstream media is not uh
is not uh necessarily they you know
they'll dip into the hyperbole sometimes
right i guess you know somebody
commented out of this this private
meeting that that happened
around like the realities of where the
game was and how it launched and they
took that around with it and it became a
thing where they're blaming halo they're
blaming this right the fact of the
matter is that you know
because of the like ariel said like
anytime you have a surprise drop in the
market it's gonna affect something yeah
and in this case two shooters yeah one
came out more polished and the one that
came out more polished it was simply
because they saw the writing on the wall
a long time before that that their game
was going to come out not polished yep
and
so you know obviously the market is
going to affect you know whatever's
happening that day is going to affect
the success of your game if your game is
not up to snuff so it was just an
acknowledgement of the market conditions
that
existed at that moment that that also
added to the fact that their game wasn't
successful um
so to this
that frostbite engine i tell you it's
always to me is the canary in the coal
mine when they talk about
frostbite and
when they say hey we were working on a
two-year-old version of frostbite
for our brand new battlefield game and
they essentially had to build it from
the ground up again
i don't know obviously i don't know the
ins and outs of dice and how they work
if they have a separate team just
working on the engine and then the team
working on games obviously because the
engine is used on other games you would
think you have a dedicated team to
making sure that that engine is up to
speed and updated for all you know all
games that run on on on on the engine so
it's just always it's that this issue
with
frostbite and their desire to use it in
as many properties as possible if you
look at kind of their decline over the
past decade
a lot of it has been attributed to
issues with that
beyond that
and the fact that i still don't think
there's enough of a separation between
the decisions made in the boardroom
right and the design decisions made
in the in the studio that actually
affect the game to come out i think
those two things there's still too much
of a confluence of those two things that
negatively impact the games that come
out and we've seen it
with you know the decisions that were
made with battlefront upfront the things
that have happened with anthem and stuff
like that um and obviously this uh with
battlefield like bad but was saying
battlefield over the past decade has
seen sort of a kind of a decline yeah so
for me
i don't know man figure it out when it
comes to frostbite or pay pay the
licensing fees and go with something
else and not worry about it it just
doesn't make any sense it really doesn't
so
again the game
the game there were a lot of factors
that contributed to this game not being
received as well as they had hoped and
you know the covert thing i think is
still very real yeah absolutely
when you think about it's only kind of
been two years if you figure you have to
change your entire way of working
during the course of a two-year period
and actually do that faster so you can
get up and running and be able to
continue to work on the game it's not an
easy thing to do so for me
there's a lot of things that attributed
to it i think they need to figure out in
general how they work with this engine
and how they apply it to their games and
a better cadence of
you know if the game is not ready
you can't tell me that you looked at
this game
and you thought it was ready to go like
i just don't i don't understand and to
me like i said before it just feels like
the boardroom still has too much
influence on what happens on the ground
floor when it comes to
these games and where they should be and
when they should come out
and
it's a sad thing to see because
battlefield is a giant
is a giant and to see it reduced to this
sucks yeah i'll jump and i really got
much ahead i mean
the you know the legacy is everything
and and to me again when when you when
you kind of total line with
wanting to release a game in a specific
window and to me i should have caught it
when
the delay they said oh it's going to be
delayed and i'm i'm the guy that's like
yo when i hear a delay i get excited
i'll be like yes
yes take your time brother ain't no need
to rush this out especially when it's
something i love like i love battlefield
like i want you to take your time so if
you feeling internally but when when the
delay was like yeah two weeks i'm like
hmm that's that's a very short
delay like that's it like okay like
so to me it's like your intent is still
to hit this target and we get it money
development i get it you know
i do feel yes halo infinite played a big
factor in the fact especially the fact
it's a free to play multiplayer as well
you know so that that definitely you
know plays into it but
you know with the state that this game
launched i it was again i used the
godfather reference like look what they
did to my boy i'm not going to see it
like that i'm not playing it until
like i fired it up and i'm like nah you
know saying i got to come back to the
drawing board it's too many basic things
that are missing
and yeah i mean as far as the engine
stuff i i don't know i mean
if if if internally they knew
that this is a it's going to be a
challenge really learning this new
engine
or for moving away from frostbite then
you need more time and you need time
allocated because here's the thing
what's the alternative now the brand is
tarnished
now people are looking at it and saying
yo
what's going on you know battlefield is
now kind of like the laughingstock out
of we came into this saying yo how is
halo going to survive
versus call of duty and battlefield in
the same window and now look what's
happened you know i'm saying halo is
still here you know yeah they got their
issues but nothing to the extent of this
you know what i'm saying so
yeah it's it's a sad thing question yeah
okay what's up bro because it's like
because i think the thing that we forget
sometimes because
not y'all but like gamers in in in
general they don't understand the dev
perspective breaking that like
battlefield having bugs all that stuff
and y'all not being happy with it
completely justified how you feel about
it that's how you feel um and i
completely understand you say hey i want
this game to be better i want to be
cleaner i don't want to uh all these
things to be wrong with it i get that um
from the uh the conversations that we
don't have are the conversations like
what are you willing to give up for that
to be like perfect on day one good point
so are y'all are y'all willing to have a
super short game remember what they did
to that that one sony game with the the
uh the werewolves and whatever and
everybody got mad they ordered the order
the order yeah the order they they tried
it it was a clean game out the gate
wasn't a lot of bugs wasn't great points
but everybody was super mad that it was
so short but like the it was small but
it had everything you wanted in it right
so like
you can't have it both ways you can't
have these super big games and expect
these studios who are massive they might
have 800 people or whatever but there's
still there's never enough people um to
test for everything there's always going
to be these bugs that they don't see
stuff that they don't know about until
it's out right um and i'm not i'm not
saying like give them a pass or anything
like that i'm saying like the sacrifices
the balance of of what are you willing
and you're making a good point no no i
just want to jump in one one other thing
because
where you're making your point resonates
with me is look i have been on the
record i felt halo infinite should have
been
delayed even to this this one right but
when i was listening to the joseph
staton interview
and it came down to the quality control
and they like look
we got a decision to make and
when it comes to co-op on launch and
forge right
and he chose i'd rather them
the core gameplay and the quality of the
base of the game be worked on and then
we ship these other things that are core
features from every other halo 8
franchise that other people are very
upset including myself i was but when i
heard him break it down from a
development standpoint i said you know
what
if that's the case that's going to drop
i would rather them choose the core
gameplay mechanics being functional and
it's a working game as opposed to
features you know even though i love it
i'm i'm co-op to the depth that's
traditionally hurts me even say this but
if that was the decision i'm always
going to go on the quality of the game
because to me
that is what's going to keep you alive
if the core gameplay is fun
and stuff that then i'm fine but once
this is where i lean solves what i
understand where you're going into the
way i leave software it's like
but internally
you gotta know
hey we might not meet this target
we might not meet this target right and
and and if we have to sacrifice okay
great we're sacrificed but my question i
guess with battlefield which was so
confusing
was the delay because it was like
i get it that to me that's a that's an
internal recognition we need more time
we need something but why only two weeks
i just didn't understand that that was
my confusion but i would play no i i get
that like in real quick i just want to
address the chat real quick so they
understand where i'm coming from i'm
saying it's really really easy to say yo
it needed more time yo they should have
did x y or z yo they should have just
like worked on it forever until it was
perfect i'm saying let's have a harder
conversation and try to understand their
perspective as well and not just say oh
they trash they need to do it right
right facts i don't feel that
the thing is though why i can't 100 get
on that kind of i i had a logic i had a
lot of oh my god
i got ideology whatever biology yeah
we got it is they
they did take that conversation they're
the ones that offer us
they're the ones that offer us the
content they're the ones that promote
the content this game didn't have a
campaign in it let's keep that in mind
it was strictly multiplayer
i'm saying that from a standpoint i can
only speak from a consumer standpoint
and an influencer standpoint and when i
bought that game
i didn't buy it but you get what i'm
saying like the game was clearly busted
it's like look i don't think it's
i think it's probably about 50 50. i
would probably put a little bit more
blame on dice because
of this isn't the first rodeo they've
had and clearly they've had multiple
games come out that wasn't standing up
to people's uh standpoint i mean people
battlefield five i know a lot of people
didn't like battlefield one like
for the most part people have been
saying that battlefield has been in a
huge downtrend for years and this is
just the straw that broke the camel's
back when you look at it from uh you
know what's going on with you they stay
how i see it
when do you honestly see people bring up
competition in the statements
like to me they generally try to stay
away from bringing up other people's
games they don't really do that that's
not standard i wasn't it wasn't a
statement i mean
somebody somebody
the conver the the context of the
conversation got out and then it got
contextualized differently it wasn't a
statement like somebody took those words
and turned it into that it's like
someone listening to a meeting
internally yeah and then yeah then we to
me you bring up halo you're bringing up
halo because you're saying look
halos blindsided us it took a lot of
them of the of the pump that we was
having
and that's that's what that what
happened there i don't see you bringing
a payload without trying to throw some
of the blame no they did no they did no
they did it they did in fairness they
did they they they went in on themselves
or themselves oh yeah i get that well
i'm not saying they didn't go on
themselves so i'm saying that from a
business aspect i don't see how you
would bring up another
entity without trying to put some of the
blame on that entity nah because if you
think about it this way look at this
right
if
they say a game comes out just as broken
as it came out route
if there was no halo out at that point
the player base would have been bigger
on battlefield regardless of how bad
that's what i'm saying they they were
saying look halo stole some of the ump
and like i get that i get to didn't
directly do it but to me you bringing up
the game in general means that you're
trying to
to put some kind of blame on why your
game wasn't successful on to that game
but regardless if it was negative or
regardless if it was positive and
regardless if you didn't intentionally
try to blame pla halo you were saying
look at the end of the day
halo stole some of our spark i think
it's part of it i think part of it i
think i think it's it's just listing
factors to me this is like having an
internal discussion
if we offline and we like yo why ain't
iop hitting
500 000 subs
right and we go yo
because you know san
or weapon francisco podcast is doing
that i think it's okay
to say as long as that's not the basis
of your thing
right they were trying to do it like
intentionally or right or anything no i
get that i get that and then as far as
i'm blaming the engine right they made
the engine
no no no no no nice mate i agree i agree
nobody else knows how to use dice dice's
frostbite more than dice how are you
going to blame the the company that made
the actual engine that they can't use
their actual but i think sometimes what
it is is like you have to have you're in
the midst of making this game right
you're in misproducing this game
sometimes the real conversations maybe
don't happen where you have to sit step
back from a moment right because you
have your head down you're making the
game like ariel was talking about
earlier like sometimes he like he made
his head he made this game kind of head
down he didn't have any help so you
aren't seeing other perspectives while
you're making the game right so you're
not neces you're so entrenched in it
that you're not seeing the errors that
you're making right so acknowledging
that in an internal meeting to me
is like is the most honest you can be
like he was like yo the fact of the
matter is halo wouldn't help the
situation at all because even though we
came out and we weren't the greatest in
the if we were the only ones out there
right
they would have been playing our game
and nothing else yeah again i think
i think when it comes to me is it's like
look
they're the responsible for what
happened about they are but they're
owning it
i'm talking about just the battlefield
scenario in general not like really
their statements it's like look like
like at the end of the day
i can't really like maybe dicey i i'm
just starting to be on that someone else
needs to be in charge of battlefield
like why they got vince in there to your
point because i mean hopefully vince
would do stuff but vince's got a lot of
stuff he's got a lot of things he's got
overseer and it's like hopefully vince
will be able to get that studio straight
but
i'm at that point was from 343 like
you had another like the difference
between this and halo is i feel like
this game
halo actually succeeded in some ways
this game did like this might be one of
the biggest flops that dice has ever
done
what they said they said they could say
it's like a thousand live people playing
on steam at once the numbers are really
really bad yeah it's just like no man
like at this point
you might need to figure something else
out or maybe get rid of the entire
management because that's pro maybe
that's the issue dice is managed
there's a certain point where you you go
you you have to choose you have to be a
gamer who's mad about the game or you
you you want to be a
a commenter on the industry um and
that's that's why i brought up that
earlier point saying we have to
understand the developers perspective to
a certain point about why things happen
right that's all i'm saying we can't hop
back and forth and say yo the game is
broken i don't like it and they should
have did x y and z with development they
should have pushed it back they should
have did this as far as like industry
stuff okay um we we like not not just
this podcast but but all gamers in
general need to pick do you want to be
grown-ups and have real conversations
and figure out why things happen and
give constructive feedback so that the
change that you want actually happens
or do you want to be mad i mean they
made that adjustment though there's no
campaign
they they
they they ripped the campaign off and
still delivered a buggy game i can't
give them any glass like at all
i can sit here and judge your podcast
and say x y and z is wrong and that you
have so many viewers so you need to be
doing this so you need to be doing that
but in real life there's things that you
know come up there's things that happen
that you have to kind of understand i'm
just asking for people to understand
that developers are real people and
games have bugs and people make mistakes
and if you don't like it don't buy it
i'm not telling you
they did this with battlefield 5 too
this isn't just one entry in the
franchise
i get that but i i think the comment
that you made about how okay they took
out the single player
it almost feels like you're assuming
that they had less work to do so why
why i mean if they put it if they took a
single player game out it would still it
would have less work to do it had less
work do you know what they lost people
than doing a campaign in battlefield 5.
so to me
if they took the campaign out that was
it
i can't assume they have less more work
here's the thing we got to be real and
this is the part
we have to be clear we are not in the
building
we're not in the building that's like me
telling you i know everything that's
going on in your house that's like me
telling me you i know where why you
ain't was on the mic five minutes ago
you know what i'm saying like
it's it's it's that kind of thing and we
got to be careful that part i'm not
giving nobody no passes as a consumer
it's up to us like yo i love the
battlefield franchise i personally feel
it's on a decline i'm not supporting it
until it gets back and i'm with you
there i'm with you there on a consumer
level but at the same time we got to be
careful of saying like yo
they should have it all they had to do
kind of stuff is because we don't know
what's in the building we could only go
by what's reported right
all i'm saying is we did the same thing
with with halo halo's doing this halo's
doing that we're saying you know maybe
bonnie ross isn't the right fit for it
you know we were saying all this
i got to keep the same energy i love
battlefield i have not been part of this
video in a couple of friends and until
they show me improvement that's fine why
should i assume that dice is no that's
my best fit not nothing nothing try to
tell me that i can't have an opinion
because i'm always not about not having
an opinion does that have an opinion
it's okay
no it's not that it's about like like
arrows said making the distinction about
being mad and i'm mad i'm not messing
with them
and equating that to x y and z that you
believe they need to do so it's like it
can't be both you can't have it both
ways right you you have to you can you
can be this entire podcast about us
giving our opinion on stuff that we
don't know
but we did it with call of duty we do it
with all right but you have a dev
telling you have a dev telling you
that it's a lot more gray than you're
kind of making it seem but at this point
what are this point that sometimes we
understand like
i used to go in
like i'm getting simple when we had
jason ronald
all right
and we like yo back compat program this
status fire okay you know what i'm
saying you know i'm rise son of rome all
day vibes on the wrong greatest 900 p
game of all time still got the pin from
day one on the launch right so i'm like
yo
you got all these games you bringing
back this you bringing back that
where the hell is my fries
all you got to do like you know what i'm
saying you got to do it right
again like
why is these joints not happening right
and then i had that wait hold on let me
finish and then i had the tough
conversation with him one time right
like all right help me explain because
it doesn't make any sense like y'all
drop in my opinion i felt they're
dropping the ball on this right so he
goes look uh this is what it is and i
can talk it now it's public record now
but this was back then right and he's
like look
there are times when we go through these
games
and we sift through all the code and the
game was 99
running
but the 1
on the final boss at the last level
broke the game
right and as a result we can't add your
favorite game or your favorite feature
to this thing i used to have
conversations about quick resume yo fam
how are you talking quick resume and
title x don't have it and it just came
out you supposed to be cause i'm
thinking yo what's going on y'all
dropping the ball so sometimes it is all
aerodynamic saying it's okay to
criticize we do this every podcast
you're right addict i'm not coming for
you all i'm saying they're they're lying
man i wasn't feeling that like i really
wasn't like
it's just like i
we give our opinion on everything yeah
but it's
on hold on let me let me finish though
cause i'll let you talk
you could give your opinion but if you
don't know what's going on in the room
with new information is presented you're
going to get upset
you can't you can't have it both ways if
there's information you don't know and
then it's presented to you it's okay to
have a change of repeat it's not like
we're going back on our word you got you
can't act like you know everything
that's going on that's what i'm trying
to say in the room all i said was from
what's been going on in the industry and
what's been going on with battlefield
because it's not one game it's not two
games it's three games because people
didn't like battlefield one right all i
said was maybe the management at three
at dice maybe that needs to be replaced
i wasn't saying that i know what's going
on behind closed doors i wasn't saying
that i know if they're having ups and
downs all i suggested was okay maybe
they need to get rid of the match
because we've seen with scenarios like
bioware that it is sometimes the
management that gets done absolutely
the whole thing and all we're saying is
if we have dice on and they tell us yo
this is what was going on but that's all
i'm saying we don't know
so stop acting like we know what's going
on in the room
that's all i'm trying to say
always saying is that the reality is
more nuanced than that
it's not everything is not black and
white there is sometimes grey in life
that sometimes you don't have the
information it's just a debate back and
forth adding listen it's
we have an opinion we're trying to
convince you of that opinion and you're
not feeling and that's fine but at the
end of the day nobody's telling you your
opinion's wrong i'm not telling you i'm
telling you our perspective on it that's
it nobody's told your opinion's wrong
like you feel how you want to feel we
just countered that feeling with our
feelings that's it and yeah now i was
just trying to bring in some context
from people who's being brought up who
not in the room like their point of like
you know people from ea i don't work at
ea i don't know anything about their
development but you know if we don't
talk about them and talk about you know
uh what they should have did and
shouldn't have did we got to bring the
context that we don't know that's all i
was saying that's all i was saying i'm
just saying like and it's not wrong to
have an opinion and to be upset and say
yo i'm not supporting the game because i
see a downward trend no one is not
saying it all i'm saying there are cases
that come out then you go oh wow i
didn't know this was also going on as to
why expectations weren't matter whatever
i'm not saying that's the case sometimes
people need to be fired sometimes people
need to go i'm not i'm just saying let's
just get full context before we make
definitive statements all the time and
everyone that has the right to have
their opinion but look we're gonna move
on because again messi i want to keep
going with this yeah
topic and then let's go
all right cool so
super chats let me run back a little bit
we don't have that many
on a different note does anyone else
think of the hokey pokey song every time
they hear sony boss hiroki to toki name
mentioned you're on another level sir i
don't know what you're talking about
then we have avantas with the 7.77
uh super chat saladin and many more
waiting for all the iron lords and the
in the launch of which queen sorry sir i
would not be there must have as always
to the iop crew in chat
then we got cypher pole one cypherpope
192 five pound super chat ea releasing
the game in the state is shocking they
make bank for microtransactions so
releasing a game like this is either
negligence or greed again an opinion
like
rubber knob hundred dollars thank you oh
no i'm gonna have to sing this am i
mm-hmm you put your right foot in you
put your right foot out you put your
ryan's foot in and you shake it all
about
you do the rookie to toki and you turn
yourself around and that's what it's all
about to the hiroki to tokyo yo they
ridiculous wow why did i have to read
that thank you sir i appreciate it
dragon heart yo b 10 superchat do you
think we will ever get back to the point
where investors will be will back off
their death teams and let them cook up
and release games when they are ready
let the dev pick the release date upon
completion so again that's enough that's
that's an assumption i'm making on my
part that the that the boardroom has too
much influence on devs so
if i ask ariel that is that do you think
that's a reality ariel
oh i have no clue
okay
all right so that's it we are caught up
next final topic no doubt let's get it
final joint hold on before we move on
it's clearly we got to clear the air
there's a little tension it's our
history
we are going to have this podcast and we
are going to agree and we're going to
disagree on a lot of topics we're
passionate about
me and attic have gone through this a
lot and that's still my brother and
there ain't no beef like that you know
there's times when he's made points like
this and i've come back to him and says
you know what
you were right i was wrong about that
you know what i'm saying all i'm saying
is in this particular case in my opinion
we don't know the information you know
what i mean i'm on some i want to get
the information in his opinion he's like
yo i'm not feeling that he's like i'm
not i'm not hearing for the excuses i'm
not and that's okay too so it's not
about me suppressing that i just wanted
to give the other side because i felt
the other side doesn't get enough talk
and that's what i was trying to convey
but as far as me and attic that's my bro
you know i'm saying so we're not going
to do this whole splitting up the
podcast that's not happening no it's not
that yeah that's not it's just passion
we love what we talk about you you ain't
got me there man i've left the podcast
if you got me exactly
you see you'd see my window just leave
listen you know how it was funny is this
over how intense we've gone to each
other and then other times we come back
to the other one like yo yo you was
right about that we just got to see how
that particular situation played
that's all exactly and it's i don't know
all this talk see i see talking to check
like nah it's kind of like this
bro
like we're here to either agree or
disagree that's what public discourse is
yeah that's what public discourse is and
we're not always gonna agree and we're
gonna be passionate about it and at the
end of the day it's always still up i i
listen
go find another podcast that's gonna
have them exactly they're not going to
have people cursing each other out after
that type of discourse it's just not
going to happen so no doubt no doubt so
that's all i wanted to say so let's move
on all right last one this will be quick
capcom's got a website up
countdown right now at eight hours
capcom games capcom hyphen games.com a
lot of rumor in these streets shout out
to jeff grub grub snacks he put this out
according to venturebeat he's saying it
is potentially
street fighter
six so one i want to bring this to the
round table
you know what do you guys think if it is
street fighter are you excited for that
and then i do have a second question
which is a little controversial a little
spicy one since we continue in the spice
today it's been a spicy podcast um
street fighter 5 if it was um exclusive
to playstation
so if it is street fighter 6
how are we feeling if it will continue
to be
exclusive or multi-flat so let's start
with with neil then we get this the real
man
i don't really like exclusive stuff so
yeah you know i ain't really got that
opinion no doubt all right so you're
okay so either way you you find whatever
whatever so you want you hyped for
street fighter or no if you were hoping
something else yeah yeah yeah and you
know fighting games ain't really you
know where i'm at right now sometimes
i'd be like all in the fighting games
like you know it really depend on my
move but you know i like street fighter
i like the art style a lot
yeah no doubt no doubt attic what's up
man this is a big hot one
street fighter 5 was um exclusive to
playstation we always tend to bring that
up and get some backlash from time
and then we have this rumor that grub
who's the track record is pretty strong
that is strange street fighter 6 in this
countdown what are your thoughts sir
uh
if it's street fighter i'll be
disappointed i am going to be real with
you i wanted to i wanted to resonate
evil but uh you know if
i feel like if it was street fighter
they might do it at a different outlet
but then again if street fighter is not
exclusive the only place you could do is
like evo and sony owns evil now so if
street fighter's not ex i mean
they might let them announce that there
if it's a multi-player but i feel like i
don't know
part of me feels like it's resident evil
but then jeff grubb comes out and says
it's it's street fighter like maybe it's
both
maybe it's like an actual like direct
kind of thing and it's not just one game
i don't know or maybe it's they uh
microsoft announced they bought capcom i
don't know like
no clue what's going on man but uh
regardless what it is if it's resident
evil i'm gonna be excited if it's street
fighter uh you know i'm sure a lot of
head-to-head fighters is gonna be
excited for that because i know the
head-to-head fighting market the fighter
mark in general don't get a whole lot of
play uh they get games like what i mean
we think like at least when i enjoy
something like i could play like the
likes like falsely arbiter uh star
renegades like there's a lot of genres
that i love and adore that i could play
indies but when it comes to fighters
even in the indy market that's like far
in between like actual balance well good
fighting game so i hope it's a fighter
man i hope it's street fighter i want it
to be resident evil because i'm selfish
and that's what i want but like
i would i wouldn't get mad if it was if
it was straight fighter because i know a
lot of people like that i know k mega
would would go crazy
i know they want that game so let them
have that you know what would be
interesting
if
the re if it's something different and
microsoft is making uh microsoft have
them make a killer instinct and they
announce that instead
um
because it's like
street fighter is a big deal so i think
they would go to this kind of degree for
when is it officially launched like
when's the all right looking at the
website right now capcom hyphen
games.com
looks like after the refresh it is
eight hours in eight hours they are
going to reveal this so i'm assuming at
midnight right some midnight yeah
midnight for us eastern
they are going to reveal something on
this website that they are clearly
promoting and it's like i said man i
don't really care what it is i probably
won't play resident evil day one anyway
it just depends it depends what comes
out that day you know eldon ring that's
around i kind of want to
dip my toes in that no no
i don't know what's going to cut it
i'm cuz because games come out so
frequently now i'm all about when stuff
coming out not necessarily what it is
like you got obviously genres that i
love the most like turn based games um
you know grid space turn based games
rpgs in general uh you know some action
adventure games not many you know those
games come out that they take priority
but for the most part you know if it's
if it's street fighter i just hope it's
not an exclusive that's all
i ain't going to play it and to be
honest with you i don't even care if
it's exclusive but i know a lot of
people that really enjoy that brand and
street fight is one of those things
where when i look at street fighter i
don't see an exclusive brand
but people buy it as an exclusive title
and i hope that isn't the case this time
maybe
it's gonna be wrong
he said it's gonna be 70 i'm done i
ain't
it could be 80 90 it wouldn't bother me
someone said maybe a lost planet or a
dead rising
i mean it's you know it would be crazy
if we say all of this and there's none
of it
yeah we're gonna be interested what's
your thoughts street fighter what's up
i'm kind of with attic man i think where
i hope it is kind of more of a director
and it's multiple things and not just
one thing
um because again like like they
mentioned those those franchises they
haven't seen a lot of day for a long
time like yeah bring something back that
you haven't seen for a while i'd love to
see a lost planet um you know
in a brand new engine looking real nice
so yeah
um
when it comes to the street fighter
thing though again we're living we're
living in very strange times you know if
you tell me they were announcing street
fighter
6
after street fighter 5 being exclusive
on playstation if you told me that a
couple of months ago
with them you know owning evo or whatnot
i would have said
it's probably exclusive because again
place they're making playstation the
place to go to play fighting games that
is a fighting game definitely
misappointed here for sure right so that
that's kind of still stands but then
when you look at how the world is
changed and you you know bungie's games
are going to be everywhere and they're
going to be
it like i said this last week i said we
this these are unprecedented times and i
anything that any game to me that
requires
an audience that requires a community
around a huge community to be truly
successful i think it only makes
business sense to put it everywhere that
you can right so if it's exclusive and
if it's street fighter and it's
exclusive i would be surprised um i just
think street fighter 5 was limited on
the playstation 5.
uh
i just i i never really saw that making
a lot of sense that back that basis all
the back oh the bag made sense but
that's what i in your words i would call
that not the best bag to have not every
bag because
we applied it and we applied it to the
quality might have been no not not at
all not at all i think that's back when
capcom wasn't the greatest financially
because i know they've been doing a lot
better uh recently so you know maybe
that wasn't the bag they wanted but that
was the bag they needed they needed
yeah it's it's it's like the dark
knight it's the bag we need right now
and maybe maybe now since they're in a
lot better place financially when sony
hits them with that they're like you put
another zero on that or you can walk out
the front yeah exactly exactly so so to
me like i i don't know man i whatever it
is something new from capcom like like
addicts said they've turned it around in
a big way
uh the past like five six years you know
with the success of monster hunter
res evil coming back in a big way
um so i'm excited for where it goes
because street fighter 5 to me
quality wise was fantastic but there was
something about a lot of new characters
weren't hitting kind of it had that
street fighter 3 vibe where a lot of new
characters weren't hitting the way
people want that to happen right right
i would i honestly i would love an alpha
four oh give me alpha they are they
talking rival schools too
or
you never know
marvel versus oh
then you know you got to look at
when they announce big titles they try
to do a little bit close to like a fair
time zone that gets the core audiences
that that game is going to apply to the
fact that this comes out at midnight
at
in the states and like maybe like 10 on
the east coast maybe it's something that
for japan
for like the eastern side of the world
maybe it's not even for us maybe because
at the end of the day you know
it's kind of like when they do e3 they
always try to make sure you know when
sony goes they try to go live for the
day
to make sure that they're at least in
the same time zone or or not like mad
late but you know they're like yo it's
gonna be it's going to be midnight at uh
on the east coast in america let's let's
throw it on there on there they're not
going to care about this yes
maybe it isn't anything we're talking
about you know it could be a rebrand in
the coffee for all you know like yeah i
mean we got to see i think shout out to
jeff grubb usually on the money with
this so when i saw that i was like hmm
he out there with his chest out he's
saying he's fighting six like definitely
i eat even i'm like usually when he has
his chest out he's right yeah he usually
so i ain't gonna usually go against him
with this one but i just find it
interesting because
i want i should have i didn't get a
chance to research how street fighter 5
did
financially for them you know we know
they got a bag up front the exclusivity
and then the game i know it improved it
kind of was rocky as far as certain
things feature-wise and character-wise
in the beginning but then i heard it
just continue improve improvement to
improve and now are they in a position
where they go you know what
let's spread this out i am very curious
if this is multi-flat on that that's
what i've really said like to me it's
very it's not gonna bother me either way
because i have the playstation i'm gonna
pick it up so if it's over there like i
did with five but i am curious because
sony is committed to fighting right they
are committed to evo they throw they
they bought them you know and that's the
only thing i really want xbox to improve
on like i really feel like yo what is
going on i talk about hashtag just one a
lot but where the fight is doing kill it
i'm not even the killer instant guy and
i feel like colors think need to get
some love and why is not a studio a sat
attached to that we talked about wb with
the acquisitions and stuff like that and
i feel that would be great because
netherrealm is in that building that
helps you know secure that need so i'm
all about plugging holes in needs and
for me xbox always it's been the
fighting the hashtag just one type games
and then to me yo you obviously japanese
you got you got all your bases covered
you know i'm good are you ain't gonna
hit car complain no more you know what
i'm saying that's just me
pie in this guy fan like this is all
draft picks kind of thing but yeah i'm
very curious guys
so i'm looking at the numbers and so
apparently
as of september or november last year
they were only about 300 000 units short
of being the number one seller
we've seen throughout the years
franchises that was back in like the 90s
and stuff like they've double tripled
quadrupled their old numbers because of
how much the the audience has grown over
the years so maybe that doesn't meet
their numbers
and now they see there's a caveat also
street fighter 5 they they did they did
three editions of that the arcade
edition oh okay and like ultimately
so whereas for the older games that went
through all those revisions they have
them all separately as separate skus
whereas all those sales numbers for all
those different versions of street
fighter 5 all together right and then
you got to look at there's one thing for
that success but then there's internal
expectation as far as what they
themselves thought street fighter could
be we don't know what that is so in
their mind because you know like our
activists said debunk you and sound like
yo you didn't you sold billions of men
but you ain't re reach our expectations
you know i mean so you don't know what
we don't know what's in the building but
anyway look i'm dying to see what's
going on i want to see how it looks and
um i'm definitely for the fighting
community so i'm about it i want to see
what's going on exclusive or not but
that is all i got so i'm going to get a
super chat and then we get a body i'll
just read this poll i can get the poll
now and then you can do it or what you
want to do yeah we got like we just got
a few that's it okay cool actually uh
no we got like two we got [ __ ] jay
remember for eight months thank you sir
addict are you reviewing elden ring
unfortunately not uh couldn't couldn't
get a cold man couldn't get a code i
mean but i will be reviewing it it would
just that game's long you guys like you
have to be better with me i'll probably
take me a week maybe two weeks to review
that game i mean next week next week i
again will the iron bank will come
attic will have his copy
and addict will have his copy and i'm
gonna have mine as well so we will
definitely have impressions next sunday
i know a lot of people i know people are
not allowed to say the game that they're
playing but yeah i'm assuming a lot of
people don't think right now
right now i ain't playing this so i
could say i'm not playing yeah so we'll
have our impressions uh come next sunday
no doubt no doubt
and then the last super chat ram c 5
super chat there's no excuse for
releasing a game like that in quotes is
an opinion
in quotes as well no campaign equals
less work is an assumption two different
things all up though
look when it comes to that like there's
no beef there's no attacking we if you
think that's bad don't don't don't
listen to our race don't listen already
bro like
i just learned what when me and carl get
into it like i just i keep quiet yeah we
but we gotta both go to our corners and
then we come back with a little like
about that uh one more one more split
difference two dollars over chap xbox
should s-h-u-d bring back deadlines why
you gotta call out the spelling though
damn
because it was purpose for his purpose
boy you know
bring back b.a.k.a
and by the way guys you know you know
that that shirt that you guys uh take
some of you harass king with see the
shirt
[Laughter]
that's okay let's drift let's go
sort of talk about no no what else we
got everything yeah we're good all right
last poll with the release and mostly
positive review reception of horizon
forbidden west who do you rank as
playstation studios top game developer
the choices are
gorilla games are they back in the mix
b
naughty dog
c
insomniac or d i don't care it's all
about that organic growth and bungie
shout out to all those rockstars
you already know the bestie lauren's
gonna be in there i kind of wish you
would have put an actual studio there
because i'm curious with people yeah
part of me yeah if i was like feeling
should have left it out maybe you should
just change that now because we all know
they're going to go for that almost
guarantee a lot gonna be funny this is
xbox the problem is already hot already
got it it's gonna go up yeah yeah yeah
you're gonna get it next time next time
we'll do it we'll do another one because
you know d is always we always have fun
with thee but yo salute but of course
the legendary real saying
okay they already being messages
ariel knight never yielded the update
rock with us for four plus hours saw
lords fight cry spicy chats paddles
and everything yeah thanks for having me
man i appreciate you brother very proud
of you of your journey what's going on
see you put the update out and like i
said i i'm always going to salute you
know diversity in gaming i know that was
another spicy topic today just talk
about that but um no i'm proud of you
brother and to see
your journey not end and to see whatever
you come up with next you know we want
to support you where can the fine people
find you what you got going on
yeah just uh twitter you know uh aerial
night um but hey if you want social
support check out the game leave a
review if you like it if you like if you
hate it if you like it whatever you know
let me know what you think um i i take
all the the real critiques and feedback
you know i'd love to hear it no doubt no
doubt we're going to put that up in the
chat
right now so for those who missed it
earlier and we'll also do a little outro
with it so y'all can get a feel of the
vibe for those that came in late so stay
around that's what this is website all
platforms y'all we got we all we're
going we're on steam we're on epic we're
on switch we're on games with gold we're
on playstation you know what i'm saying
yeah y'all calling it y'all y'all
calling me a fan boy but i'm on
everything
not cause they see you know what it is
you just commenting on horizon yeah and
they
i was given advice like two years ago
it's like i had it because i used to let
people call me like an x bought fanboy
and stuff like that it's because
literally just because i made positive
xbox videos and they're like you can't
do that because if you're an influencer
you don't all you don't want to dig
yourself
in the ground it's just an xbox person
but if you let people call you that
they're they're going to insist that
they can't take your opinion on anything
else valid so i started going against it
man people don't like that people want
you to just let people
get out like me though
my hoodie is more about this being a
dope hoodie than being sony
i feel that i feel that i'm just telling
you how the logic is the fanboy live
they're going to they're going to give
you a nickname they're going to play
let me stop anyway be the best of your
salute man good to have you up in the
room lord addict it's been a while since
we had a spicy while trying to think the
last one we had
it was about the switch switch yes
that that was a long one forget the
switch was worse we had to really back
away from each other king had his steps
kick it yo when king got to be the voice
of reason between being oh you know
salute what's good with you bro you can
find me on
okay just hear me out oh hear me out
i am unsure if i will have an attic show
tuesday okay
the the the witch queen is on tuesday
i can't i might man i i part of me feels
like
to consume my destiny drug i don't know
we'll see we'll see if something drastic
happens monday or tuesday nah son you're
supposed to make that show come out we
don't care about your personal destiny
love you gotta make sure you just stop
delaying our attic show what's funny
what's funny
is i have the uh i'm known for the attic
world so if i'm that selfish what makes
you think i won't be selfish over my
gaming time
but you know we'll see i'll probably end
up doing it because it's like an hour
and a half two hours it's not like it's
that long no doubt uh so extreme destiny
too uh i don't we we will be let me
point out that most likely i will be
streaming the witch queen on twitch but
then when when the ray drops we'll be
streaming that on youtube so you guys
can uh uh you know look in the messiness
hopefully it won't get serious now i
will say
don't expect that same type of nicey
nice nicey nice super positive energy in
the rain when people messing up because
when we rain
it gets real
y'all thought this was something man
listen to us
i've literally gotten into a people in
the community because i've kicked people
from lfg because they weren't doing
their job right so you know it it it
gets really really really toxic and as
someone who doesn't play destiny
watching them raid
is an absolute joy
because there's so much smoke you see
the smoke yeah i told you to stand on
the plane i'm watching you you did not
stand on the plate
you know what it's really bad when i
switched spots of someone so i could
watch someone else did it
you know what's the worst when you wipe
and then you see the damage numbers and
who ain't doing enough dps yo phil what
are you using what are you you why is
the gala now what's going on why is your
numbers low then it become a battle who
doing nothing worse than hearing someone
on the team say what you got what you
food shooting with
yo
you're preparing for drama yeah the day
one raid is funny because that last
trade i remember when y'all you guys had
to go from platform to platform and then
when you were blind and you didn't know
where you had to go and people were
dying and falling off or going back to
the beginning of the stage and didn't
know where they were
and then you got the person who's not
honest that they don't know what they're
doing and no no i knew what i was i was
doing i was where i said i was supposed
to be
be watching world first and then act
like he knows yeah he'll be like all
right guys i think we need to
be like yo why are you looking at him
you know what's funny is like well jump
in there you gotta find a glitch we're
not doing it oh that was a big yeah that
was a big one screaming it was screaming
like y'all got a glitch to get past this
part nah
nah we gotta do this we gotta do it
anyway no doubt so that's gonna be lit
soft man what you got going on
now big shout out to ariel knight like i
said bro i i
i appreciate everything you're doing big
big uh big shout out to you for the game
i love the game when it came out i'd
love to see it still being supported and
again bringing brought up to the
forefront in the community um and like i
said before also i love your candor i
love the fact that you're not afraid to
say what you feel because a lot of times
the conversations that people they're
conversations that
many people are willing to have
in a forum where everyone everyone can
say what they feel and everyone opinion
matters and
sometimes because the the subject matter
isn't you know nice and you know like my
wife says fuzzy and strawberry like my
wife says um things don't get addressed
in the way that they're supposed to and
i appreciate the fact that you're always
going to be forthcoming and honest in
that regard so again
big shout out to you bro you know we're
always gonna we're always gonna support
you brother for sure always man always
gonna love it and like i said everybody
else please cindy i love the king man he
wasn't feeling well at all he had every
intention of the kingdom like the
kingdom let me explain to y'all like for
kingdom forbidden west glitches yup he
would have been about all the smoke i
would have been interested in his take
on certain topics and then you know he
would have went in on the ten dollar
thing and certain thing you know he feel
but you know send him some love he like
i said his attendance is pretty much
impeccable so if he's not feeling well i
know i'm kind of under the weather
myself so you know take care of yourself
sometimes we got to shut it down you
know solve is done and attic has hit me
we all have this mentality look
health is wealth bro we got to take care
of ourselves it doesn't don't make don't
be killing yourself for the sake of the
podcast after this i'm going to be
taking some dayquil and i'm shutting it
down i ain't doing nothing you know i
mean so look send some love good to see
y'all in the chat again ariel knight the
legend good to have him in the realm
shout out oh shout out to mr batman
shout out to kiss moonshot the um gaming
forte who pulled up last minute to hold
us down for the king again salute to the
chat it's always a good to agree to
disagree and i'll tell you what you want
to hear what you need to hear everybody
enjoy your sunday i'm going to let you
get this promo and we out peace
we back
back
[Music]
[Music]
at the last minute street fighter 2 with
the lords and members let's go yeah
let's do it all right
watch the trail again
we back
back
[Music]
[Music]
tell me
get back at it
[Music]
you